hey
everybody out there what's up it's
saturday night and it's us again
here we are if it's streaming i just
went in there and it's not there yet
okay it's there well yeah your thing is
it take it takes a while
it takes a while for um everyone to get
in
and for all the damn choppiness yeah
everyone together they're all coming in
now
i tried to get everybody together yeah
oh hi clay hi hi hi waiting for
everybody to like come here yes
um here come all the comments xanada's
there what's up my man
hey hey zack hey you literally just
started i know you got here just in time
we haven't even talked about anything
important yet i mean
some people could argue that we probably
never talked about anything important
but
my boy zach said melissa's in
there's melanie there's
yeah there's dab brush yeah i think she
she sent me a message earlier and said
she was going to set her alarm so i
guess that worked out
stephanie seth okay 17 says tom you're
such a nut job
i'ma join that job yeah you are kinda
yeah
he knows he admits it and then um
they're all coming in
all the way from glasgow holy crap
all right let's give him a few more
minutes
got 22 coming in seattle in the house
high fuzz butts
yeah where is our little fuzz butt she's
out playing i got a collar on so if she
wants to take a break she can
i can let her out she can go out on the
porch yeah
let's get this second let's get this
kayla rolling
i like how now you're doing like pouring
the drinks actually
on camera before they drink on camera
completely it makes it like way more
exciting
yeah it's like part of the ritual it's
like part of the ritual
santa asked what's the new picture
behind you guys oh yeah we did we just
talked about on the matinee but i don't
think we had it like for last episode
oh we didn't have last night i don't
think so because we just got it this
week right
yeah unless he's mistaking it for a new
picture but that
is yes sophie friend of the show who's
also stayed with us
yeah last year i think it was last year
yeah uh she sent tom that for his
birthday frank for zetta
yeah and it's on canvas that's not
opposed the barbarian and it's on
canvas it's a portrait of me and jenny
our essences are
yeah as tom pointed out but for zetta
yeah i mean we might have had it by last
week because i thought i like i
remembered thanking sophie on last
week's show i tried to keep track of
like everybody that i'm supposed to
thank on the show because i thank him in
the week too but then i like to thank
him on the main show
last week maybe he didn't see the show
last week yeah maybe
yeah i think what the hell what what did
we talk about last week i don't even
remember
oh we did uh that auto the auditory
stuff like yep and everything like that
and like i said i'm afraid to go back
and listen to that show because
we were like so hammered by the end it's
like i probably only talked about the
topic for maybe
half an hour total and the show was like
almost four hours long
we went off on so many tangents you guys
what else is new uh zach's asking about
tom where'd you get that
video about the people attacking the
tanker with the song
don't look at me i don't know what
tankers must be talking about those
riots
when everybody jumped on that damn
18-wheeler
and they were playing the song i don't
know man i just sent it to you that
shit's on
youtube he doesn't remember i don't
remember all that yet people send me
stuff and then i share it
five minutes later he doesn't remember
anything yeah
no i remember i remember it's just that
you know what i mean uh
there's a lot of y'all out there and
you know they keep me on top of things
people sharing stuff with me
you know a lot of times you guys will
share something with me and somebody
just shared it already
to you know gate sent it to me just you
know five minutes before
so i just stay up on i stay on top of
things just with people sharing
and then if it's good i share it to
everybody else
yeah because you're magnanimous like
that yeah uh raymond mcdonald says
interestingly i was just about to watch
citizen x and then i got your
notification that's spooky
you know what's weird i was just
watching citizen x
right before we started recording
because i only found out i've been like
researching the
the case that we're gonna talk about
which in case you hadn't figured it out
is serial killer andre chicatilo
um and i just found out i was like hey
there was like a teep i think it was a
tv movie although there was a lot of
swearing in it so maybe not
um that was made in 1995 about the case
it had stephen ray in it donald
sutherland was in it and melva staunton
was in it there was like all kind of
like famous people jeffrey damon
uh played uh chicatello and uh i
actually i didn't finish it but i
watched like most of it like before we
started
uh actually quite a good movie i was
like i was surprised i feel like it
needs more
exposure dljm says he's going to get
drunk tonight he's got
i think parma violet gin and cherry
pepsi gin and cherry pepsi i didn't know
that would work
that sounds kind of good i don't know i
have to see it myself i'm just like i'm
a big you know i'm a big uh
vodka advocate i don't really like
tequila however
every now and then i get a wild hair and
i want some gin
and i never have any at the house for
whatever reason i just like every i
don't know it's like whenever
we're at the liquor store i'm like man
bombay sapphire looks kind of good but
it's like i never
i'm just like i feel like i don't drink
it often enough to justify buying the
big bottle of the [ __ ]
but i do like it every now and then but
the only thing about gin is that if i
decide
one night when we're going out that it's
like oh it's going to be a gen night
because i'm in a gin kind of mood
it's drinking gin and tonics are very
delicious
but if i drink more than two or three of
them i will throw up because
they're so like acidic i can drink those
all night long which is weird it's like
i can drink other stuff and not throw up
and
feel mostly fine gin and tonics with
little twists of lime are pretty
refreshing they are yeah
for some reason you can get pretty
hammered on them
and you don't look drunk i don't really
understand it
you don't act drunk yeah i guess
like it's like an old man drink it is
yeah and i like them though i like gin
you can drink a lot of them and they
don't really affect you
and then but the nice thing about it is
that even if you do puke it smells nice
like juniper
it's like it's like medicine
it was every now and then like once
every couple months i just feel like man
tonight's gonna be a gin and tonic night
yeah they're nicer because i drink them
slower because i'm so used to drinking
vodka that i can like hammer that back
like pretty fast but like gin and tonic
is like so tart that i tend to drink
them slower but if i do drink more than
three i'll probably barf
you ask me what's for dinner i don't
know it's for dinner yet we had a snack
before we started the show yeah just so
we wouldn't drink on an empty stomach he
just made like some cheese sandwiches
cheese sandwich on pita real quick
fried it in a pan with oil with the nut
oil uh butter
yeah so it's like a crispy pita bread
yeah it was delicious with uh
cheese it's monterey jack and [ __ ]
cheddar
yeah yeah where's yeah we don't we don't
know what you sound
it's funny because you know last night
it was friday night so
and we didn't have anything to do
particularly so we watched a new movie
which we will probably be reviewing
tomorrow i'm not going to spoil what it
is
but um so after that we were kind of
like well we're
a little bit inebriated so we just went
back to watching
you know the uk kitchen nightmares yeah
because those are like really comforting
i don't know why
even though we've seen them like a whole
bunch of times kind of like watching the
old hauntings the old
yeah it's just like something well you
don't have to like super pay attention
to it because you kind of know what's
gonna happen and it's like then every
now and then like gordon will say
something really funny and
you know like he'll get in a fight with
one of the owners and they'll be like
plunker [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
like very funny you sit there and trip
out over what some dude believed
some [ __ ] some dude believed yeah i
mean what he thought he was gonna do
yeah yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] like how could
you think that that would happen
so we started watching that and then
like while we were watching it it was so
funny because i think we were watching
the curry lounge episode
and like all the indian food that like
gordon was making on there i was like
i'm gonna make that i'm gonna make any
of you tomorrow and then this morning he
comes in my office and he's like
we were really drunk last night what did
we see on the show that i was going to
make today because
i couldn't remember i said it must have
been some kind of indian food because we
were watching the curry lounge yeah
what's funny is that i'm out of chicken
and i don't have anything like lamb
if i were to make indian food they had
to be with like beef or pork
so it would be like totally forbidden
indian food
[ __ ] that an indian would not eat yeah
we've had it before though man [ __ ]
like like beef curry and pork curry is
[ __ ] really good
yeah it's good it's it's not real
authentic i guess but for thailand it
would be
yeah if you do it more like in a thai
kind of style you can get away with it
don't eat either i just kind of i feel
like
the thing about it we don't get i mean
they do sell lamb here at the grocery
store but it's not
real common like usually you know you
can go and get lamb chops but that's
about it
so i i really like lamb actually
so we don't make lamb a lot at home so
whenever we go
you know you know before the pandemic
and everything we used to go to memories
of india
one of the best things they made was
lamb karma and i would get that like
every single time just because
everything else they serve is good but
it's like you can make it
and it and it's just as good or better
than what the restaurant has
but we don't do a lot of lamb so
whenever i go there i always get lamb
korma because their lamb korma is
amazing and that's like one of the only
things that we never figured out how to
replicate
i don't know why i don't know how they
make it but it's [ __ ] delicious
okay we've got 36 in and we're 10
minutes into the show let's go ahead and
uh
start our introduction shout outs and
stuff like that
okay um let's see we got like i said a
lot of these shout outs i think i
already
did like on some of the various uh live
streams by the way today's show
andre chicago chicatilo yeah
one of the worst serial killers yeah
russian one in the world
really like world history he's an
[ __ ] yeah well he's dead now so
that's okay
they executed his ass
but yeah so uh so we're we're gonna talk
about that guy
holy crap okay so we're gonna do some
shout outs like i said these i think
i've already done on
various other live streams but in case
you didn't
catch those uh i wanted to give a thank
you to
louie for sending us some movies he sent
us the terminator and all
like a blu-ray like special edition and
also sent us uh
i think the secrets in her eyes which i
haven't watched yet but it's like i've
been wanting to see that
um because i don't think i've seen it
yet not that i remember i've seen a lot
of movies but i don't remember seeing
that one so thank you very much for that
i also wanted to thank logan for a
paypal donation thank you very much
also we have a new patron uh named mark
in
and uh also one of our previous patrons
sydney has doubled their support so
thank you
very much for that like i said thanks
again sophie for sending us the
the uh conan thing back yeah well we
can't call it conan it could mean
yeah just a barbarian yeah because he's
just a generic barbarian
[Laughter]
well uh for zedd didn't have rights to
[ __ ] uh uh the what's his name
for conan but he did do all the artwork
and all this different movies in the
books so yeah it's conan zach says did i
see the pictures where chikatilo had his
dick out i did indeed
um well was there anything there
well it was kind of like a little bit
above that or it was like
you know it was like fuzzed out a little
bit okay i'll get into that a little bit
but one of the
uh speculations well not even
speculation because he did actually kind
of say this himself but the reason why
he became a serial killer because he
didn't really become a serial kill until
a little bit
later than a serial killer would
normally become a serial killer
uh was because he was impotent right
so you have a choice evidently
i mean that's kind of how he played it i
feel like he's just like well
my dick didn't work the way that it was
supposed to so i just had to kill people
so
right because that's how that works
that's how [ __ ] works i guess
i suppose [ __ ] right that's some
crazy [ __ ]
this dude was a [ __ ] lunatic he's a
[ __ ] lunatic but like i said he's
i found him interesting because he
didn't start until later in life which
like i said is unusual that's the end of
the shout out yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah oh uh we got the uh
we got the we got the uh the screens for
the shirts done
yeah we burned the screens yes sir we're
gonna have four
new ones why don't you hand do we have
those handy and a piece of paper i'll
show them what's coming because there's
a lot of people involved
let's get the box yeah now the main one
that we're doing
yeah is the logo one i'm very proud of
this logo one yeah
and i'm excited i'm making i'm making
some for me that have this
on it like in like various colors white
piece of paper so you guys can see
all right all right
yeah in case i think we showed these
before but not on the main show actually
if i reverse it
well yeah then you can see it the way
yeah it's going to be white on black
obviously
yeah it's going to be white on black and
that's going to be our new logo it's
going to be a full screen yeah that's
going to be like the main thirteen
o'clock shirt
okay that we're running with at the
moment i'm gonna have a bunch of bonus
stuff
and then we have these ones too this is
this is two shirts
okay it's backwards it won't be
backwards on the screen because it
reverses everything
okay yeah yeah now this little box up
here that's what's going to be on the
back
yeah that's going to be back in your
shoulder blades yeah it'll be that
that's our label and then there's a
whale and yutani
and then a whaling corp that's two
different shirts i'll probably do those
like in a uh
i just shot him on one light blue or
light green to make it look like a
little digital display or something
that's yeah we were actually looking for
some lime green but they didn't have it
didn't have anything we went to
michael's but they don't have they had
blue and red but they didn't have any
green
this was gonna be some badass [ __ ] you
guys are gonna like this we're gonna
give this out too
get it you get it
that's some bootleg [ __ ] there because
that's the ford cobra logo
i just put we just put twiskin in that
[ __ ]
well yeah i'm not going to get in
trouble as long as i don't sell them
avoid so some people depending on what
your contributions are you're gonna get
several shirts
on this shipment because we had some
people when we first started streaming
sending us hundred dollar [ __ ]
chats super chats you guys are gonna get
several shirts
yeah because i got like a bunch of
extras so i'm gonna sort out like
you know because some people are gonna
get like more than one and we actually
told people like that we're gonna go
get that bombay sapphire jay thank you
very much oh thank you very much very
much
i might next time i'm at the liquor
store i'm always tempted he's a
subscriber
he's a uh a patron yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so he's
got [ __ ] come
yeah okay that's dan right dad yeah
you're in the uk yes yeah i'm pretty
sure if we're gonna send some [ __ ] to uk
we'll probably send several shirts at a
time because it
works out on [ __ ] well yeah it might as
well because you gotta pay for the
shipping anyway and i have to go inside
the post office right so
with everyone's cooties we're behind
we're gonna be taking care of all
patrons and people that [ __ ] sent us
big chat
big uh super chats yeah because like i
said i you know i feel bad that we must
like
because i used to do them every quarter
but you know we had problems with the
[ __ ] panda
panda and we couldn't get the shirts and
then like you know because jiffy shirts
said shut down for a little while
they're factory and then like we
couldn't get to michael's to get the
paint and all this other guys but i got
all fours now i got
all four screens done yeah they're all
and a huge box of [ __ ] shirts here
and jenny and i are going to get here
and we'll start printing these damn
shirts
i'm going to cook that [ __ ] up i'm going
to cook it up like crack
yeah you want us to send you some crack
too no we don't have any crackers
let it crack all right do you want to
start talking about the serial killer
somebody says i already have plisket not
this pliskin this is a brand new design
yeah like i said the one that i did um i
did one for the
zazzle store which uh you had one of
those and it kind of
it fell apart it's really weird because
i have like i have a whole bunch of
uh shirts that i ordered from zazzle and
none of them did that to the same extent
and you didn't really wear that or wash
that anymore than any of the ones that i
have
a [ __ ] part so i said man i gotta get
very strange a badass [ __ ] snake
pliskin shirt and you see
for that first snake pliskin design that
we made for zazzle
we couldn't play any games with
copyrighted [ __ ]
so that's not the design that i wanted
this one i just showed you
that was the one i had originally
envisioned didn't that right jenny yeah
the ford cobra logo was just said
pliskin
and i thought that's a [ __ ] awesome
then so just evoke snake plisket
yeah but they won't let you do that on
zazzle
because that cobra is copyrighted yeah
it's copyrighted so if you try to like
upload something that's
a copyrighted logo or something like
that they'll be like hey you can't yeah
and then the alien and prometheus
weyland and weyland yutani shirts that's
[ __ ]
a lot of people copy those they're not
copyrighted yeah i've seen a ton of
those because i feel like
yeah that's the thing it's like if you
invent a company
in the in your movie universe
like and you have a logo for that like
is that really copyrighted like
automatically or do you have to
like see i thought not they don't think
it is because you can make
like for instance like i made a shirt
based on
dead ringers that just said mantle
brothers or mantle twins fertility
clinic or whatever i didn't use any
stills from the movies i had to use
something that evoked that
but you can do that as far as i know
they have to go through the process of
copyright and [ __ ]
right and you see and if they don't then
it's open no that's my understanding of
it
that's what i thought now here's like
i'm not a copyright lawyer but here's
another design that i want we'll we'll
do this in the next couple months
i want a canon films [ __ ] print and
do a [ __ ] yeah i wrote that down i
worked on canon films on mtv logo
yeah we'll put 13 o'clock in the [ __ ]
back but we'll also get one out for
canon films and if you remember the
canon films logos i think you guys
probably like that
thing like that yeah three lines real
retro 80s [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah thank you maria thank you very much
thank you very much let's see
everybody's saying
do you want to start talking about about
serial killers or not um
are you not ready yet there's 34 people
in there we can go
all right we can go now uh yeah we're
talking about
uh andre chicatilo like i said one of
them guys ready to start the show
one of the worst serial killers in world
history probably
should i bring dennis in here that's
what we'll see you should have done that
before because before we started before
we went live
let me get dennis he was just like i was
like i feel like maybe dennis might need
to weigh
in on the topic especially because
there's a
a large sexual component to these crimes
i'm really happy i'm really happy that
you brought me on the show thank you
i'm ready to talk about this guy at
chicatello i'm gonna let you handle most
of it jenny but
thank you i appreciate that i i trust
your expertise
all right but i'll be here for any you
know any input if you if you need
anything just
just holler i definitely will i will
holler for
for your dentist right now man [ __ ] you
dudes
i'll talk to you don't
[Laughter]
i love how you can just see his little
bubbly head like right there at the
bottom
[Laughter]
i wish i had a place where i could put
him so he could be up here
is there anything i could sit right here
let's see do we have something we can
see oh i'll put him up on my can
there you go put him up on my can put
him up on my can so he'll be right there
here we go
yeah there you go his little head going
dude
he's like more prominent
free speech for tests beastness movie
says tom must be buzzing already
yeah i'm just starting to kick in man
he's just uh it's funny because you i
went back on my rad140 cycle so i'm
feeling [ __ ] good
that's good i'm on therapeutic
we're doses 140 mk and mk
yeah you were kind of like doing
something with it because you were
trying to
yeah because you were kind of sore from
your life yeah and my shoulder was
bothering me so i said [ __ ] it i'm going
to hit some
red if i can get that [ __ ] healed up so
i'm just gonna [ __ ] i'm not gonna do
full cycles like i did before i'm just
gonna
use it therapeutically to repair damage
that i do to myself i hurt myself
oh i hurt myself all the time let's go
ahead and get to the show though
i'm getting drunk i'm getting
sidetracked you can't be drunk already
you've literally
drunk like half no not even half of it
it just started to hit no
it just started to hit me okay i'm just
starting to feel good
years yeah we're only like 21 minutes in
you were gonna be incoherent
by the way it was strong this one was
pretty strong well yeah the one you made
for me was really strong too i took a
sip out of it and brought it in here i
was like holy crap
just kind of getting warmed up for sure
all vodka was like a little squirt of
apple juice [ __ ]
mason jar just trying to put on a good
show for these people
yeah all right i hurt myself all the
time as a great song title so
i know i just want to play that nine
inch nails song it's like so [ __ ] sad
all right so uh andre chicotilo
a ukrainian born uh soviet era
serial killer now he actually ended up
confessing
to 56 murders
of women and children between 1978 and
1990
uh and was actually ended up being
convicted of 53
of these murders and he was executed in
1994
but he ran rampant for quite a long time
um
a lot of that had to do with you know
him just being a serial killer picking
people at random
but some of that had to do with um you
know
soviet era bureaucracy um the fact that
they
didn't really want to acknowledge that
there was a serial killer running around
because that was kind of like
not a thing that was happening or at
least that's what they wanted people to
think i'm not sure
they didn't want that tomorrow [ __ ]
the socialist utopia if having a [ __ ]
serial killer running around the middle
soviet union
didn't want to admit that and plus
another thing is you have to understand
the mentality of the day i grew up
during that era so did you but you know
what i mean i had kind of a military and
government angle on it even when i was a
kid
coming from the kind of family that i
came from which is all state department
stuff
when you're dealing with the soviet
union they were totalitarian they didn't
they would never admit
publicly to the people that they didn't
have a wrap on everything yeah
so this whole thing about well we got
this guy raping women
young pretty russian girls we can't
catch him the party would never admit to
that
because their whole claim to fame was
knowing what you
thought that's how [ __ ] micro
managers these dudes were
they claimed to know what you were
thinking and you know the [ __ ]
soviet empire in the eastern german it
was a rat culture all they did was rat
on each other
[ __ ] when eastern when eastern europe
collapsed
we got our hands on all that [ __ ] uh
uh
intelligence data from um eastern europe
the stasi
and it turned out 66 to 68 of the
eastern germans
had ratted on the other ones yeah
everybody else they were just rats
you know and uh well it really did
foster that environment yeah
trying to like save your own ass by
knocking on others
a rat a tattletail and a [ __ ] narc
that's what they do
all right and and to come forth and say
that there's a damn
serial killer and nobody's ratting him
out is a
is an admission of weakness so yeah
one like i said that was something i
mean once it got to a point where they
couldn't
um hide it anymore to their credit they
did actually get in there and try to
solve the [ __ ]
but it did take them a really long time
to get to the point where they were one
willing to admit that there was a serial
killer running around and they knew that
it was
the same person because um the mo was
very uh
distinctive but you know they were very
reluctant to
ask for help like um you know ask the
fbi for help because the fbi were you
know several years ahead in their
profiling and uh all that other type of
stuff
so you know the fact that that happened
did like
you know lead to them like taking a very
long time to catch him
although like i said once it got to a
point where they couldn't really ignore
it anymore
they did actually go about doing things
in a normal way that we would actually
do it every year
yes to answer your question i do love
the movie doctor strange love that's
awesome it's a [ __ ] masterpiece and
writing in the war world and it is not a
story that is a [ __ ] documentary
question dr strangelove is a documentary
all right
and it has some of the best cast of all
times yeah it does have some comedy and
comedian but that's true
that's that's ex that's it that's that's
what the cold war was
yeah that's what it was and that's and
it's it's interesting because i was just
before we started recording i was
watching the movie citizen x and they do
go a lot into
even though some of the characters are
fictionalized or kind of like you know a
put together
uh you know kind of of a bunch of
different people like put into one
character
um they do go a lot into like the
bureaucracy behind it and why it took so
long to catch them and it's like they
were you know how the
you know the the ruling party was more
worried about
you know optics than they were worried
about catching
the person um so it was
you know it was a fairly accurate movie
even though like i said they did
fictionalize some things
now so as i said now chicotilo has been
known by various
um kind of splashy nicknames uh the
butcher of rostov or the rostov
ripper um you know because that was
where most of his crimes took place
so let's kind of talk about his
upbringing so he was born and
please forgive me any russian listeners
i'm sure i'm going to mangle
every single name and every single city
name and every single victim name and i
apologize for that in advance
uh because i know no russian whatsoever
so um so he's born in this kind of uh
small village
called la uh
i guess that's sort of close to
something like that yeah so
yes which was in the ukraine now when he
was born
this was not too long after um stalin's
uh you know collectivization of
agriculture because the ukraine at the
time was you know the bread basket of
the soviet union's there was like a lot
of farms there
and um you know all of the crops and
stuff like that would be taken
so there was a lot of famine
um and it had slightly improved by the
time that uh andre was born but still he
grew up kind of in the aftermath of that
so um one thing that
you know no one is sure if this is true
but apparently this was something that
andre's
mom told him uh whenever andre was being
bad
was that hey it was either his brother
that was
like you know before he was born or a
cousin or something
uh he got taken by the neighbors and
eaten like he was cannibalized
so it's like you better like watch your
p's and q's or
that'll end up happening to you like is
everyone's starving so yeah
they're gonna eat you yeah that's not
[ __ ] there was actually yeah i just
don't know if that particular kid
if that happened right that was just
something they were telling him that was
in
russian soviet area culture especially
in prison
they had a [ __ ] big old [ __ ] war
break out in
inside russian prisons called the [ __ ]
wars
and in that in the [ __ ] i love that
yeah the [ __ ]
that should be a band name the [ __ ]
wars were about guys who were released
from prison to fight the nazis in world
war ii
and after the war was over they were
sent back to prison because they [ __ ]
broke the deal with them instead of
giving them their freedom like they
promised them like you
fight the war will free you no stalin
sent them back to prison
and they went back to prison the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] regular
um convicts went to war it lasted a long
time and cannibalism was
like thousands tens of thousands of
people were eaten
in russian prisons during the [ __ ] wars
well i mean the thing is it's like
you can't really blame people if you
don't like if they don't have any food
what the [ __ ] else are they supposed to
do and those like that's
what happened in this situation too it's
not good i think in pr i think in
russian prisons they had food it's just
that they wanted
bonus food and they were already pretty
mean
and why why if you're gonna kill an
adversary in prison why waste all that
meat
so they were eating them well yeah like
i said just like in the cartoons every
time somebody walked by they look like a
big one
i think that was happening out in the
country too you know [ __ ] when the
soviet union was cracking down on all
those kulaks
and then the kulaks were under so much
pressure they became like these wild ass
[ __ ] hillbillies
and evidently they were eating people
that they didn't like too there was
cannibalism is a part of [ __ ]
communism north korea is
rife with cannibalism especially during
that damn
uh was it that 10-year period
after the [ __ ] death of kim uh of of
of
of kim il-sung back in the 90s evidently
uh
their population contracted a lot during
that time because
the economy had collapsed they couldn't
feed anybody and whole towns were
starving to death
people were eating their children yeah
brutal [ __ ]
yeah we have so much to thank
you know what i mean we so much to be
thankful for living in the [ __ ] west
those totalitarian societies are bad you
know what i mean
they're not well-meaning and then when
they [ __ ] up i mean
they just don't give a [ __ ] these people
[ __ ] kill each other and eat each
other
i mean imagine if you had a government
that just sees you as a drain on their
system and you're just excess population
they're like [ __ ] you we're not going to
feed you anymore no issue for you
you know what i mean that's happening in
[ __ ] what's the place in down central
america where that's happening right now
that's happening right now um
it starts with it in nicaragua right no
no no no
it's not nicaragua the one that had uh
[ __ ] you guys can help me out i'm
getting drunk
getting [ __ ] up holy crap venezuela
it's so early that doesn't even start
with an end
i don't know they're all the same
venezuela venezuela
all the countries think of nicaragua
yeah venezuela is [ __ ] bad too
there's cannibalism going on there also
uh just a couple years ago they were
fighting the cops and eating cops and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] wild [ __ ] man
centralized
centralized economies don't work
especially when they're written
especially when they're run by idiots
and most of the world and most of the
world's a bunch of [ __ ] idiots
yeah but yeah so like i said i'm not
saying that cannibalism didn't happen
because obviously it did
uh on his way let's see yeah yeah zyden
knows exactly what i'm talking about
i'm me and santa that [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
walking him through his [ __ ]
first ar build he's building a [ __ ]
badass little ar got a little booster
coming and everything
but yeah so so just nobody knows if
that particular kid was cannibalized or
if that was just something that the
parents told him like to get him to
behave
so they obviously were very poor like
many people were
uh in the at the time and lived in a
one-room hut
and uh farmed thank you very much zach
yeah zach's asking me a question have
you ever heard of
nazino island that's actually somebody
asked me about that it's a cannibalism
thing um
i actually have that on the list of the
topic today okay like eventually
we'll probably get to it before the end
of the year i would imagine because it's
yeah it's coming up on my uh list
because somebody asked me about it
before i don't remember if it was here
if it was somebody else but somebody did
ask me about that
so i'm serbia saying how you doing bro
hey what's up yeah
ectoplasm ectoplasm
i love it yeah so so this is a very
small uh
place that they live it's like a little
shack he slept in the same bed with his
parents
now interestingly um he was a bedwetter
up until his teenage years now as we've
pointed out many times on this show
before
bedwetting is one of the what they call
the mcdonald triad
uh which you know is an indicator that
the person will become
a serial killer later on in life the
other two things uh one thing is
that bedwetting one thing is arson and
one thing is cruelty to animals
however i think maybe in his case
now every source that i read about him
didn't say this but a couple of them did
there were a couple of sources that said
that andre might have been born with
hydrocephalus otherwise known as water
on the brain
and apparently one of the side effects
of this is like kind of spinal deficient
because it like [ __ ] with your spinal
fluid and you know the fluid around your
brain and
whatnot so that might have been the
cause of the bedwetting and it also
might have been
the cause of his uh in you know
him not being able to maintain an
erection uh later in life which is one
of the things that
you know probably paved the way toward
him being a serial killer
so this might have actually had a
physical cause i'm not so sure about
like
because like i said it's a very common
thing for serial killers when their kids
to be bedwetters i think it's more
usually in those cases i think it more
has to do with
anxiety issues and you know things of
that like more psychological issues
but in this case it might have been
something that was actually
physically wrong with him and the same
thing that caused the bedwetting
might have also caused um him to not be
able to
i don't understand bed wedding what is
this you're just sitting up in bed
yeah [ __ ] it man i gotta take a leak but
i'm not getting up well no they're
sleeping
you just let it out they're just sleep
they're sleeping
it's usually you're asleep and you piss
on yourself
is that some kind of a choice that your
subconscious is making
see i'm not sure because whenever i'm
okay so this is like maybe tmi but
whenever i'm sleeping
and you know and i have to pee you get
up well no
i start dreaming that i'm looking for a
bathroom
yeah but every bathroom i find either
has like creepy serial killers
in it or it's too disgusting to use
which i think is my
brain's way of saying hey dummy wake up
you have to pay
for me every single time so whenever i
know that i start dreaming that i was
like i find a bathroom and it's like
this disgusting
it's like it looks like the train
spotting bathroom yeah you guys have
seen that
then that's my brain's way of saying hey
get up you have to go to the bathroom
jenny can be my witness i gotta take a
leak i just wake up and go [ __ ] take
a leak
i don't even don't even think about it
i'll wake up and then go
throw up and then get back to bed like
it didn't even like nothing
like it didn't even happen she's got a
fear throwing up i enjoy throwing up i
[ __ ] brace myself here come
it's there's a place where you take
baths and showers and then there's a
restaurant
we have a restroom in the bathroom i
don't think that i've ever seen another
house with this i'm sure there must be
another
because in it's the the you know the
master suite if you want to call it that
but where the the main part of the
bathroom there's like the sinks in the
mirror and then there's like a bathtub
and then a stand-up shower but that part
doesn't have a door so like from the
bedroom into that
part it's just like an arch yeah so when
you're like just in the shower so this
is like if people come over they have to
like leave the whole room because it's
like if you're
in the shower everyone's going to see
you like if i put a curtain up there
we probably should but then we have an
actual toilet
like the little yeah just the toilet and
that's it and then we got a [ __ ]
closet for two that's like the size of a
small bedroom
yeah like a walk-in now that has a
pocket door but we don't ever close that
because why the [ __ ]
pookie loves that [ __ ] closet that's
her room yeah she thinks that's her room
yeah because she just goes in there and
going ladies and gentlemen you go in
there after the shower and she's just
like hey
throw wet towels on me hey sit on the
floor
and she's like it loves she loves that
[ __ ] i don't know why she's so weird
but yeah so so i don't know like i i
feel like
well the thing about it is that kids
that wet the bed a lot
it usually like i said normally it's to
do with
um abuse or uh anxiety issues or
something like that so it usually
so i don't know if it's so much
bedwetting itself that's pointing to
somebody like maybe becoming a serial
killer but
bedwetting is like a side effect of
other things that might
make you a serial killer later on like
you know sexual abuse in your family or
you know high stress high anxiety other
things like that
but i'm just saying i don't know if this
is true or not i think in chicotilo's
case
um the bed wetting which continued into
his adolescence
um was maybe due to a physical issue
that he had that was also causing his
impotence because
like i said it does mess with your
spinal fluid which can cause like
urinary problems and problems with your
uh you know your urinary tract and stuff
like that which would actually uh
suggest that maybe that's something to
do with it but
because he was a bedwetter and he slept
in the same
bed as his parents uh every time that it
happened his mom would beat the [ __ ] out
of him so
you know not a good situation and also
like i said he
grew up thinking that his older brother
had been eaten
by the neighbors so now whether or not
it actually happened nobody knows
whether or not
yeah no one knows if it actually
happened or not um you know like i said
i'm not arguing that it didn't happen to
other people because
it did but i just don't know if it
happened to his particular relative but
he believed that it did anyway
now i will note that as much as i think
you would think if it was true they
would have [ __ ] exacted revenge on
the neighbors
yeah you would think somebody ate my kid
i'd [ __ ] kill you well yeah most
people would
i understand they probably just made
that [ __ ] up yeah i
kind of feel like that was one because
it was something that was going
on yeah maybe like the mom was like hey
you better behave it's kind of like
you know it's kind of like it's [ __ ]
up but it's like your parents like
telling you hey the you know the
like the boogie man yeah the boogeyman
are the crazy person the town's gonna
come
get you or something like that or i'm
gonna put you in an asylum or [ __ ] like
that
like that's what people use no if you
ate my kid i'd [ __ ] you up
well yeah i might eat you i might be
like hannibal lecter right
well that's what i mean my sister so i'm
gonna eat you yeah piece by piece
please so you're still awake most of the
time right something weird like that
if you [ __ ] over pookie i'd [ __ ] you
up well yeah we've said that multiple
times
well like i said we were talking about
this last time i mean pookie is like
a child yeah in a way she's kind of like
our child she's a member of the family
yeah so it's like if anybody did
anything to hurt her yeah i would not
hesitate yeah
to just like remember that i don't give
a [ __ ] what the law says this is about
emotion
[Laughter]
and nobody better say it's just a cat
it's not just a cat she's like our kid
but yeah so now i should note that even
though
uh andrei chikachilo had a intensely
[ __ ] up childhood
however given the time period and what
was going on in time a lot of people had
really [ __ ] up childhoods and i will
note that the vast majority of them did
not become serial killers
so again i'm going down the road if it's
like you know
it's not good to have a [ __ ] up
childhood but i feel like there has to
be that extra
thing that'll make person because some
people have more messed up
childhoods than this and they turn out
more or less okay
so i feel like there has to be some kind
of good damn tom would eat someone
yeah he'd eat someone too to survive and
and say like you know what i mean like
uh some of these situations where people
are out in the wild and it's [ __ ]
freezing and you can't get food
like they're on top of the mountains and
[ __ ] argentina remember that book
it said it was in chile yeah yeah most
people would
uh well if you you would do what you had
to do you do what you have to do to
survive
and they didn't kill anyone they just
ate people that were that had died in
the
crash or had died and like if i killed
somebody and ate them it wouldn't be for
any kind of sexual purposes it would
just be hate or vengeance
i can understand that a little bit more
yeah but not
most of these [ __ ] weird-ass
cannibals it's almost a sexual thing
though
yeah and i definitely think it was in
this situation right because
this dude cannibalism is extremely
[ __ ]
look cannibalism is very very common in
african warfare i mean even
recently you know [ __ ] two [ __ ]
kill each other and cut their hearts out
need them to gain their strength and
you know it's just it's it's a tribal
concept
um some islanders uh
kind of have uh uh in recent
times have done this island tribes and
for them it's kind of more like a thing
of humiliation you eat a hated enemy so
you could [ __ ] them out
really well yeah because it's going
through your digestion yeah
it's like the ultimate it's like the
ultimate disrespect
right it depends on how your your
culture's gonna play it you know what i
mean i mean they have some cannibal
cults in india
right now that eat the dead but it's a
thing of respect
more than it you know it's a thing of
respect not really a thing of disrespect
it all depends on how you're
rationalizing it culturally
each culture i feel like if there's not
a lot of food around and somebody died
of natural causes
yeah i don't i don't blame people for
eating that person
there's a huge correlation between
cannibalism
and extreme poverty yes and that is
totally understandable
totally understandable like i would
never like look at the donner party or
somebody like that
where they were in such a horrible
situation
that people were dying anyway in that
case it would be dumb not to eat them
i mean i know it's horrible and i know
right you know it took a lot for them to
get to that point but if you were
desperate enough i don't blame them they
weren't killing people to eat them
you can go on google right now just go
look at chinese communist
communist cannibalism and the chinese
are cannibals
in recent times ccp members
were cannibalizing people that they
considered to be traitors
there is no taboo about cannibalism in
china
well meats meat they eat yes and that's
how you look at it there were reports as
late as as late as the late 80s
of people in big masses kind of like
these rage mobs that you have now here
in the u.s
busting into people's houses that they
thought were not good communists
and eating them and that's verified
and some of these people doing the
eating were the relatives of the people
who were eaten
okay and so politics were involved in
that [ __ ]
people think that people don't
understand [ __ ] human nature and
how bad human nature can be
you have moral panics and mass
psychology when that combines
you here in the united states you should
know what i'm talking about the [ __ ] can
go
very wrong group psychology and moral
panics
it don't it don't it doesn't go together
well bad [ __ ] could happen
bad [ __ ] could happen anywhere but look
up chinese cannibalism you'll see what
i'm talking about
somebody asked if we were starving when
we eat pookie i don't like to think
about that no
no no i wouldn't eat poopy i would
rather eat my own food than eat pokey
here's the deal i'll eat you before i
leave pookie you can go
you can go a long time without food i've
been a long time without food [ __ ]
nothing
you can do about i mean three months
people
lived without food it's not fun here's
the thing you can
after about three days you don't really
feel that much hunger
your your body adjusts to it you can
starve to death
pretty comfortably it's not as bad as
people think
yeah like i feel like the worst hunger
is like in the first few days after a
while it just goes away
somebody asked this is actually a funny
question i think zach asked like up
there
it's like if you guys had to eat each
other what dish would you make
god's ass he's [ __ ] crazy i think
i think probably with my culinary
knowledge and culinary
expertise uh cannibalism would probably
go along real well with indian spices
indian food and product because indian
food nests
i think my ass would be delicious it is
it's those indian spices can make all
meat taste good
pretty much that's what i mean it's like
if you know how to make it it's like
it's not that gross
but i don't want to be you guys are
[ __ ] you guys are trying to go down
these [ __ ] weird ass [ __ ]
directions
and [ __ ] trying to get us to say i'm
here for it i love this kind of [ __ ]
yeah this show is a [ __ ] weird show
but but i'm a freak i
understand you have to be kind of
[ __ ]
open-minded and global about this you
know maybe we'll talk about globalism
people eat other people
it's not as rare as you think uh certain
cultures
explain it in other ways usually it's
tribal usually it's extreme
poverty and it's about a loved one
giving you their final possession which
is their body
yeah as sustenance anymore i'm not using
it
right now some guys
african warlords and african [ __ ]
warriors we're gonna do a whole show on
general butt naked
okay i'm a big admirer of [ __ ]
soldiers and generals and [ __ ]
warriors of all different [ __ ]
all different cultural backgrounds and
my favorite african
warrior is general butt naked and
general butt naked was a cannibal and he
also
sacrificed a lot of children all right
um
and then he turned away from all that
and tried to and became
tried to become a good man he became a
preacher
uh but we need to do a show on general
button eventually
he was cannibal too um i don't do a lot
of cannibalism and necrophilia on this
show we didn't do that on purpose yeah
just kind of
and he was talking about sacrificing
beautiful girl children and [ __ ] for
victory in battle and
you know [ __ ] already
certain cultures are gonna yeah certain
cultures are gonna interpret things a
different way
well i think he regrets it i think he
sees the life
and i think he sees things differently
now but you can't
impose western values on everyone
there are certain people that do not
come from western societies and they
don't have those values
we're not all the same that's what
that's the beauty of diversity
is that we're [ __ ] different well
yeah it doesn't always work
yeah yeah but i would rather have
people being different and just like
squabbling with each other
yeah then everybody just being yeah
there's but would i want a [ __ ] would
i want to
import millions of general butt nakeds
into my [ __ ] backyard no
no i don't want that dude they need to
stay over there where they're at
let them work that [ __ ] i mean i'm just
saying like yes my ass might be
delicious with indian spices because
most things are delicious with indian
spices
but i don't want somebody coming over
here and just like and eating people
yeah like what i'm because i you know
i'm
worried enough about a [ __ ]
stealing my car i kind of like being
alive yeah right you know after i'm dead
i don't care you can do whatever you
want because i don't need the [ __ ]
anymore but like you know
while i'm alive just you know consult
with me first
because that's all i'm saying all right
so
they're saying dennis is tripping him
out
yeah he's like let's make his head
wiggle yeah yeah
yeah he agrees with everything yeah all
right so
uh where was i all right so as i said
uh there might have been a thing where
uh chicatilo had some kind of like water
on the brain when he was born
that might have contributed to the
bedwetting as well as the later
impotence
that he displayed that was one of the
things probably the major thing that led
to him becoming a serial killer
so then the soviet union enters world
war
ii now andre's father roman uh gets
drafted into the red army
now he wasn't in battle very long he got
wounded in combat and then he
got a taken prisoner he was a prisoner
of war
now weirdly because he got taken as a
prisoner like he got released later on
when he came back home um
basically he was vilified because they
thought he was a coward because the
germans had
he allowed the germans to take him alive
so the name of the family was kind of
like dragged through the mud
another thing that uh andre said later
was that he
forever resented his father after that
because weirdly that was one thing that
contributed to a lot of andre being
bullied at school was that his dad was
seen as a
traitor or as a coward because he got
captured
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it is yeah
but that was kind of the way they think
i i guess maybe they would have
they would have preferred it if he had
killed himself or killed and died or
been killed and died fighting then he
would have been a hero but the fact that
he got
captured and then later released that
made him a coward somehow
there's always [ __ ] that aren't
[ __ ] in combat making judgment on
other dudes who are
yeah i mean the the germans captured a
lot of russian guys a lot of them
russian guys they sent to concentration
camps though he's
he's lucky his dad survived it yeah
that's usually what they did
i'm just saying that that was one of the
things that i mean he got like andre got
bullied for other things but that was
one of the things
it's easy to get captured in warfare
like that
well he got wounded yeah you get about
left behind and then get captured
you can run out of ammunition and get
captured it's a bunch of
your your chain of command could [ __ ]
surrender and [ __ ] all of a sudden
you get captured
it's all kinds of [ __ ] that could happen
to you right so it's like it just seems
like that's [ __ ] up
that you know his dad got captured which
you would think
you know people would be sympathetic but
they were not they just considered yeah
russia's captured a whole bunch of
germans
yeah you know i mean it just happens
that's gonna get captured
[ __ ] happens yeah but yeah so andre
apparently um
you know when the germans came through
they burned uh his hut to the ground
like the hut that his family lived in
i've also seen some sources that
said i'm not sure how true this is but
that maybe a german soldier raped his
mom
and he witnessed it um you know not all
sources say that but some of them sounds
like [ __ ]
so i don't know it did happen like uh
again
just like the cannibalism it did happen
i just don't know if it happened to that
particular person or not
germans weren't known for rape although
like i said russians were
i do know of some cases where it did
happen yeah but the russians were doing
it systematically to the to the germans
when they were
got inside uh [ __ ] germany
they were actually they were gang raping
and [ __ ] killing
german women in mass now here's the deal
though
it wasn't your front line russian
soldiers were doing that they had these
second and third echelon russian
soldiers were guys that were released
from prison
it was they they were the ones that were
doing a lot of that yeah yeah us army
and [ __ ]
us army would find big piles of dead
german women nude
weren't with it all been raped and that
was uh
russian second and third line troops
doing that [ __ ]
there's all kinds of [ __ ] that happened
during those final days of the war
they'd capture a bunch of german guys
americans would capture a bunch of
german guys and say
look uh look at what they did to your
women over here we're gonna re-issue you
a whole
ammo and send you back to fight russians
go
go kill some more russians for a couple
days and then come back and we'll take
your surrender
a lot of that [ __ ] was going on yeah
because the the american high command
figured that once the war with germany
was over
that we would turn on russia we were you
know the russians and the americans
planned on turning on each other
during that war you know
it's just that we didn't realize if it
turned into a cold war they thought it
would go right into a hot war
yeah a bunch of weird [ __ ] happened
there's a good a lot of good programs on
it a lot of good research mark felton is
a dude that's big into that [ __ ] he puts
a bunch of damn
videos up all the dirty games we were
playing with the germans to [ __ ] kill
russians
in the final days of the war yeah yeah
so yeah so you had that whole thing
where
you know the whole thing with his dad
also andre was kind of
um he wasn't a bad looking dude like
i've seen pictures of him when he was
younger
like a teenager um you know pretty
attractive handsome
dude didn't look any different than any
other dude um but he was kind of shy he
was kind of introverted like i said you
know his
family was kind of you know nothing out
of the ordinary but you know his mom had
beat him for
pee in the bed and it's like he had this
whole thing with his dad and like people
picked on him because of that
um he was kind of shy so he got picked
on
uh quite a bit now he also
um when he got into like once he got
into
puberty and got into his teenage years
he started to discover
that he was impotent in the sense that
he could still ejaculate but he could
not maintain
an erection and as far as i know this
continued his entire life
um so it's like i said it might have
been a physical problem as far as i know
he didn't sound psychological if you ask
me
well it might be but there are some
physical uh you know things that might
have caused it
and as far as i know he didn't ever go
to get it checked out or
anything like that so it was something
that kind of fueled a lot of resentment
um you know later on and even when he
was finally captured
in the 90s um you know when he was at
trial one of the things like
that was one of the things where he like
took his pants down like showed
everybody his dick and like waved it
around in the courtroom
and said look at this useless thing you
know and so it was one thing that like
really seemed to because he didn't feel
like a man
i guess because he could never get it i
think i think this is all psychological
stuff that
it could have been it could have been
because it's more likely that
having those physical problems it's more
it's more likely that
physical problems did not cause these
psychological problems it's more likely
that psychological problems
[ __ ] cause these physical problems if
you ask me because there if there was
dudes that had some kind of a
some kind of physical problem and it
came to [ __ ] like
uh [ __ ] impetus impotence and potency
then that means that there will be
serial killers running around everywhere
you know what i mean it's more likely
that
he had a bad self-image you know what i
mean well he definitely
lost all that i mean because like i said
impotence is not i mean it's not that
rare
it's not that rare right um i'm just
saying that
you know i'm not i'm not excusing that
that's you know
that was kind of what he said but
you know that probably like along with
other factors that probably pushed him
toward that because
i think he felt like i think it's
problems in his head and it's a vicious
well and it's another thing too where i
feel like he had this kind of thing
where
he felt like well he was a man so he was
owed
like sex or he you know was entitled to
it
and the fact that his dick didn't work
whether it was for physical or
psychological reasons um i mean it did
work in the sense that he could
ejaculate and he could he did impregnate
his wife later on
um in a non-traditional way but
the fact that he couldn't maintain an
erection long enough to have sex with
someone in an in the quote-unquote
normal way
um i think like [ __ ] him up
to an extent that he just couldn't deal
with it yeah
so it wasn't just the impotence that was
the problem it was the fact that he
couldn't deal with the impotence
yeah what i'm saying i think it was a
[ __ ] vicious cycle that yeah exactly
that's exactly right one thing caused
another it was his mental problems
causing it
and then the impetus increased his
mental problems in his anxiety it was
like a vicious cycle of it yeah
and it started probably in childhood
like you're saying you know being picked
on about his dad and bed wedding weird
[ __ ] stuff like that so
fears of being cannibalized i mean
there was one serial killer who became a
serial killer because
his brother got killed raped and killed
by a serial killer
yeah him fantas him thinking about what
happened to his brother
caused him to [ __ ] start to fantasize
about doing that which made him a serial
killer
so you know well obviously abuse causes
more abusers
usually does yeah and that's that's i
mean like i said not always because i
definitely think there has to be a
genetic component because
obviously sadly a lot of people are
abused as children and they turn out
okay they don't turn out to be serial
killers but they're
i mean so there has to be that other it
depends on how a person reacts
yeah it's all in how you react to it
right yeah and
it's weird because i was just thinking
about another serial killer earlier
who i can't remember who it was but it
was another one that i think
the story was that he saw his sister get
raped
when she was a kid and he couldn't do
anything to stop it because he was just
a kid too and it was like you know the
guy that rich was like a grown man
and that may and then he became a serial
killer later on
and some people have speculated that
might that that might have kind of
been like a formative experience when he
was a kid because he couldn't
prevent it from happening so he was just
going to do it to other people because
some people have like this kind of
[ __ ] up
you know i did horrible things happen to
them so now they're going to do it to
other people like it's some kind of
weird revenge or some kind of [ __ ] yeah
and they almost kind of fetishize it
that's where they start to kind of
immerse themselves into it and become
one with it
and instead of being a victim of the
abuse they're trying to become a [ __ ]
master and perpetrator of the abuse
turning it around
yeah because they felt powerless right
they're gonna turn around and make it
make themselves powerful
and i feel like that's and particularly
in chicotilo's case because i think
that the fact that he felt powerless not
only because he was impotent but also
because of others like he got picked on
for other things for being shy for being
introverted
or whatever um so i think that
that was kind of the only way that he
could throw his weight around
was to attack and kill
people um mostly young women and
children
it's kind of like kind of reminds me a
story from a story that fran drescher
you know fran drescher the girl
that actress when she was young and
living up in new york i think it was new
york where she said she lived
a dude broke into her apartment raped
her he was a black guy
all right and from from then on out she
only dated black guys
it was like her way of [ __ ]
confronting and overcoming the fear
yeah of black guys was to date him
and which that doesn't seem like a
terribly unhealthy
that was the way she that's the way she
responded to it i could see that
well it'd be like the same way you know
if you had
a guy who like you said
saw his brother get raped his way of
dealing with that is he
becomes the rapist so he has another
fear from it yeah
all right so well it's just kind of like
how
kids that are bullied at home often will
become
bullies at school and they'll pick on
kids that are
littler than them because they get
picked on by their dad or their mom or
whatever and they can't do anything
about that because those are adults and
their children
so they will pick on someone younger
than them to make themselves feel
yeah powerful so they should to kind of
like you know offload that sense of
powerlessness that they feel
um you know that they can't uh fight
back against their parents because
they're grown-ups
yeah um so you can understand how that
happens like i said it's unfortunate
but you can understand why why it
happens you can understand the pathology
of it
yeah these dance moves it's called kick
the dog center right there what the [ __ ]
i'm offended as a brother
yeah that was the story of fran drescher
yeah yeah black dude raped her and all
of a sudden then she [ __ ] started
dating in the flag converted her flipped
her
that's [ __ ] up
but yeah so once uh chikitilo had
discovered
his impotence uh which was a you know a
massive source of shame for him
um he didn't have any sexual experience
as a teenager at all
other than now i've seen different
sources say either he was 15 years old
or 17 years old i'm not really sure
which it is
but apparently this little girl who was
i believe was about 11
and she had come over to the house to
play with his younger sister
and apparently he jumped on her and like
tried to say i don't know if he was
trying to rape her but he was definitely
like trying to like assault her so he
like jumped on her it was like kind of
like humping her or whatever
and she was struggling and him and her
struggling against him like made him
spontaneously ejaculate so that and
that's kind of like the only sexual
experience he had had up to that point
so i kind of feel like when he was a
teenager like he couldn't get it up
if you want to say that but he learned
from a fairly young
age that he needed someone to be like
fighting against him it had to be by
force or he couldn't
do it lawrence is in there cr clowning
about the bbc
bbc monster came and got her flipped her
flipped it like a [ __ ] pancake that's
messed up yeah
world is a weird place world is a
[ __ ] strange place
it is
so all right so another thing that
happened that probably did not
contribute to his
uh already very low self-esteem was that
so he finished his school in 1953
and i believe his dream i think it's i
think i remember reading this that he
uh wanted to study law so he actually
applied for a scholarship at moscow
state university now he ended up passing
the entrance exam but his grades weren't
really good enough to get in
now he kind of blamed this on
um you know the bad name that his father
had given to the family
and kind of resented his dad for the
rest of his dad's life because of that
even though i suspect that moscow state
university i mean they had a lot of
applications and they were only going to
take like
you know the top of the top you know the
cream of the crap or whatever
and i just feel like well he didn't
quite cut the mustard so i don't think
it was anything
particularly personal but i think he
kind of took it personally
so that was kind of another you know
notch in favor of like you know
everybody's against me everybody hates
me like you know it's
you know he already has like terrible
self-esteem and this was another blow
so it's like he's just feeling like less
and less of a man like as time goes on i
suppose
which like i said not an excuse i'm just
trying to say
this is where the dude is coming from
you know what i'm saying like why he
ended up the way he
ended up so between 1957 and 1960 he
does his compulsory
military service now in 1963
um i guess his younger sister was kind
of like worried about him because
i don't know if she knew that he was
impotent or not because that seems like
a weird thing to talk about with your
sister especially back then
but um she was worried that he wasn't
really dating or anything like that
she's like look i know this
girl this friend of mine and i'll set
you guys up
let me get some more ice for that man
okay so
uh the younger sister sets andre up with
uh this young woman now they kind of hit
it off uh the young woman was
you know very intelligent very likable
now i
i've seen some things i don't know how
long they knew each other i don't know
if they dated specifically or if it was
just kind of like a setup kind of
hey you know here's a woman have her
because like we're kind of worried about
you it seems like that kind of situation
um i read somewhere that they only knew
each other for two weeks
and then got married i don't know if
that's true or not
but in any case he did actually end up
marrying her
now what ended up happening here was
that when
the wife figured out that
he could not maintain an erection
i mean she still wanted children this
was you know this was just what you did
back this was the early
60s so you had to have a family life and
everything so she wanted children
so apparently what he would do
was that he would like not to be super
gross
like anyone's worried about that but um
he would like
jerk off into his hand and then like
stick it up in her vagina like with his
fingers so essentially like a turkey
baster method
but without the turkey baster um that's
what i heard anyway so that's kind of
like how that was working out
um i don't know if she had any sex toys
or anything i would hope so but i don't
know like i said this is early 60s and
it's soviet
it was a soviet union so i don't know
how easy it was to get sex toys
probably impossible but yeah so uh this
actually did work
um she did get pregnant two times they
had a son
and a daughter uh the daughter's name
was uh ludmila i think and the son's
name
was yuri um you know so they did have a
couple of kids
now after that so as i said he seemed
like a normal family man at this point
um you know this is the early 60s this
is soviet union
no one is really talking about family
dynamics everyone's putting on a happy
face everyone's trying to look
normal and so you know but there was a
lot of [ __ ] going on behind the scenes
that nobody kind of knew about until
later
but it looked like a normal family from
the outside you know with the wife and
the kids and all that
and he had a job and all that so 1971
um he actually ended up finishing a
correspondence course in russian
literature and uh then later got a
degree in the same subject from rostov
university
and from then he would go on to become a
teacher at various schools
now so he's teaching literature russian
language
now another thing because
like i said his personality type was
very
uh shy very introverted so according to
everything i read
he was not a very effective teacher
because his students didn't see him as
having any authority
because i guess he was kind of quiet and
he wasn't really
um you know authoritative wasn't
outgoing so
the the students essentially like kind
of ran
rampant like over him like they wouldn't
do anything he said they didn't have any
respect for him or anything like that
now he worked at a couple of different
schools uh you know over the next few
years
however he ended up uh getting fired
in about 1981 because of numerous
complaints
about him molesting a bunch of the
children um interestingly
and like i said this is late 60s early
70s
um you know molesting it was still
molesting kids was still bad
but i feel like they didn't take it as
seriously as they take it nowadays
unfortunately
sandra's over there says it took me 10
minutes to figure out what the bbc
comments are all about the [ __ ]
that's right
we were talking about the british
broadcast yeah yeah yeah for your
for your foreign duck ass let me tell
you something bbc means
big black [ __ ] yeah nothing to do with
it
big black cup all right it's been known
to flip a [ __ ]
even a man where were you getting this
maybe up in prison well the way you said
yeah a [ __ ]
well you know that usually means a dude
yeah maybe
anything is a dildo if you try hard
actually i love that
that is actually true actually uh uh
ought to bring [ __ ]
um my boy toby up here i think
yeah i think bbc flipped toby on [ __ ]
several cases
well but that dude to scare off a
[ __ ] in a heartbeat too
i got told stories about toby yeah you
know
last week wrapping around the [ __ ]
leg toby
it's just perhaps looks like a [ __ ]
40 ouncer with a [ __ ] apple on the
end of it looking underneath them down
live the times carlos says was i
watching the wrong bbc
yeah you're watching the wrong bbc
[Music]
there's like well it's funny because i
find porn fascinating because it's all
acronyms man it's like all the acronyms
that you have to like figure
you know bbc bbw
so much stuff
no i was just laughing about zach saying
anything's a dildo if you try hard
enough
i mean within reason sure sexy ass
jump on anything if it's big enough well
i'm just well i was just while you were
out
there fire extinguisher well yeah well
while you were out there like making a
drink i was talking about
um then i'm sorry that you missed this
now i'm kind of
gonna have to repeat it just so i can
hear your comments on it
okay was that andre yeah
married this woman that his younger
sister had introduced it
it seemed like essential like i said i
wasn't there but it seemed like a
situation where the sister was like you
know please get laid
so it was just kind of like here's a
friend of mine that's like i guess she
doesn't have a boyfriend so just like
just please marry her and yeah do
something with that
um so they got married and i think that
the the wife
figured out that he couldn't get it up
yeah but still wanted children because
like i said it was like a family thing
you know if that's what everybody did
so what i heard i don't know if it's
true like i said i wasn't there
what i heard was that he would just jerk
off into his hand yeah and then stick it
up in her vag
okay with his hands like like i said
like the turkey baster method but
without the turkey
right that's what i said artificial
dissemination artificial insemination
yeah i mean i guess yeah well that's a
very crude way yeah it just kind of
sticks
yeah in case you really like that that's
kind of how you did just kind of stick
it up in there just kind of
it's like here stand on your head just
make sure it like stays in there i guess
but like i said it did work they did
have two kids that's right both that's
probably just talking about how
think about how many dudes fleece
johnson turned
leash i don't know what i am
that's [ __ ] please don't google one
man in one jar don't worry i won't no
i've already not googled if you got in
case you guys
didn't know because i i know what's in
there i'm not watching that in case you
guys didn't know
johnson got released he got released
several years back
and evidently lived a normal life for a
couple years and then died
i think he died as [ __ ] cancer or
something
but felice johnson if you guys just
[ __ ] google fleece jobs and booty
warrior
on on youtube you'll see exactly who
we're talking about you're like his
marketing dude
because you mentioned him whatever no
[ __ ] they they actually made cartoons
about booty warrior
yeah well how can i know what i am with
a name like that
booty warrior that was the name that was
given to him
by the fight but by uh by other people
because he called himself well he called
himself the booty warrior he's a war
i'm a warrior a warrior
i'm a warrior i know what i am yeah okay
i see
him and if he likes him
he goes to war with it yeah but yeah so
so like i said the this rather crude
um method that andre used
uh because he couldn't do [ __ ] the
normal way did work
his wife actually did a kid so this dude
had two children think about that i
don't know whatever happened to them
so um as i said so he becomes a teacher
but he only did it for
a few years before he ended up getting
fired because he
got a little too touchy-feely with the
students
uh usually girls but sometimes boys as
well he wasn't picky
um so there was that whole thing so he
did end up
actually getting another job later on um
he started working as like
a supply clerk in a factory like you
know other jobs he never seemed to have
any trouble finding jobs which is very
weird to me
even though i guess it's not the same as
it is now or it's like if you have a
record like that like hey you molested
kids
and then you can just like walk out and
get another job somewhere else and
nobody like even questions it but i
guess back then you could do that
so september of 1978 andre chicatillo
and his family
moved to uh a place called shakti
i don't know if i'm pronouncing that
right this is a coal mining town
near rostov now it was this place
where he committed what is thought to be
his first
murder and like i said there were a lot
of them he ended up killing at least
at least 52 people probably more like 56
and maybe even more than that
so his first victim uh this happened on
december 22nd
this was a nine-year-old girl named
yelina zakatnova
and what he had done was that i guess he
was planning this [ __ ] because he had
secretly
bought a house like out in the like not
a fancy house or anything but he's
bought kind of like a crab like shacky
kind of house
and it was like kind of out like in a
rural area and he i guess he bought it
for the specific purpose of hey i'm
gonna take some victims here
because he didn't tell anybody like can
you tell his wife or anybody that he had
bought it
so he just bought this house for that
purpose so he lures this nine-year-old
girl
to this house and he tried
to rape her and of course it didn't work
out
because of his problem
uh this enraged him and so
he choked her to death and just started
stabbing her and while he was stabbing
her
he spontaneously ejaculated so like i
said he has a thing where
i guess the knife is kind of acting as a
pseudo phallus
in this situation
like that is how he gets his sexual
release because he can't maintain an
erection either like i said either for
psychological or physical
reasons or a combination of the two but
apparently stabbing
someone and killing them will
bring him to orgasm it's psychological
all right all this problem is
psychological if you ask me
this dude is a a outlier he's at the
very extreme fringe
of statistical probability
if you ask me he's got all kinds of
[ __ ] um
inadequacy issues he feels he's not good
enough he feels his daddy wasn't good
enough
big time got all this [ __ ] going on with
him
and when it comes to [ __ ] sex is too
challenging for him as his fear of
failure
overcomes him so you can't get it up
yeah
it's like that [ __ ] syndrome that
look watch the dick syndrome you're
trying to [ __ ] piss
they'll watch and they were looking at
your dick next to you
the urinal says man dude why are you
looking at it and you get stage fright
it's that's what it is then he lashes
out
okay because he can't do it and then the
fear of
future failure [ __ ] feeds into that
[ __ ] well yeah because then you start
thinking now he's in a pattern right now
like
next time it's gonna do that too and
then you're thinking about it and he
starts
right right so then he starts going down
this [ __ ] crazy ass path
where he's abducted little girls and
killing them
and he's so [ __ ] up he can't even have
sex with him after they're dead
yeah a lot of those dudes we talked
about earlier on other shows
they just don't want to be watched
because there's too much
for performance anxiety it's pretty sure
they kill the woman so they can have sex
with them so because she can't watch him
yeah that's all it is how many problems
would be solved if they would just buy a
sex doll
because before they had that [ __ ]
they have really good ones now maybe
they're waiting serial killers
these dudes are so [ __ ] up though you
know what i mean that
they probably would have performance
anxiety for the sex doll
yeah probably she's probably looking at
it yeah she might be looking
turn her over it's going to be a kind of
situation where they're going to have a
full
ai artificial intelligence [ __ ] a sex
robot
and that's going to be too much pressure
for him dudes are losers
yeah yeah yeah sandra was asking i was
actually wondering about this too when i
was uh
reading about this dude she's like if he
can ejaculate then he isn't impotent
now see does impotence mean that i mean
you just can't maintain an erection that
was his thing he could still ejaculate
he just couldn't
and he did he did he just couldn't
maintain an erection long enough to have
sex in a normal way so like i said i
don't know if that was a physical issue
or if it was a
you know so he couldn't have he couldn't
get a heart on and he couldn't
keep one but he could ejaculate
to to an extent that he did actually
father two children with his wife
even though he had to insert
the ejaculate in alternative ways
somebody just went and watched these
nests went and watched the food scott
johnson video
yeah somebody gonna have to give up a
booty
they need booty like water like a man
needs water
[Laughter]
it's like water
[ __ ] fleece johnson was concerned it
was like
water okay you need booty like a man
needs water
fair enough okay
[Laughter]
lawrence is laughing
send more vodka yeah right i might need
some more in a minute
but yeah so all right so so he kills
this poor little girl his little
nine-year-old girl
um and he dumps her body in the river
please johnson who is the booty warrior
they say who's please johnson
please johnson is the booty warrior he's
a [ __ ] convict
who liked booty and if you can [ __ ]
google fleece johnson
search for felice johnson on right here
on youtube and you'll be a little
i think it's nbc i think did a little
thing on felice johnson
in prison and he was a [ __ ] dude in
prison that
liked booty like any like booty you
gotta have booty
you know like a man needs water and
somebody's gonna have to give up a booty
somewhere you know i mean that that's
that's prison someone's something
somebody's gonna have to give a booty i
don't know who it's gonna be who's gonna
give it who's gonna give it up
somebody's gonna have to give it up and
he was a warrior about it
he knew what he was i was gross just
looked up police johnson now it's time
to delete my history
i know that feeling well like i said
it's like i [ __ ] i
all day all i do is like read about
[ __ ] terrible murders and like all
these horrible like [ __ ] sis so i
have to like
it's like people if anything ever
happened to me and somebody checked my
[ __ ] history i'd be in such big
trouble like everyone would think i was
a [ __ ] serial killer nick
no seriously i just i just write about
serial killers i'm not actually
here please johnson was what they call
him prison in prison they call him a
pump
he was a prison pump and he liked booty
and somebody's gonna have to give up
pootie somebody
he might flip-flop where he gives up
booty you give up booty you're flipping
and flopping
well that's only fair it might be
flip-flopping when he flips it out of
his pants and flops it down into your
[ __ ] mouth oh that might be another
kind of flip-flopping
have you ever said that on the show
because i've said it before that's
something that you used to say yeah yeah
yeah i'll flip it out
i don't know if you actually got it on
the show for posterity
no
[Laughter]
here at the bbc we do not endorse this
every time i laugh at british people i
laugh at [ __ ]
when the british talk about bbc because
to an american that means a totally
different [ __ ] thing
i mean intellectually i know it to be
because i read bbc news
but it's like it is always kind of like
always in the back of your head
like big black guy things like that
i would read the big black hawk news
yeah they got bbc the bwc
they got [ __ ] all these weird
acronyms like
like [ __ ] wmaf
you know what that one is right white
male asian yeah
they have all the different [ __ ]
acronyms to find anything that you want
in the scene in the world of porn the
world
the world yeah porn world you guys want
to see a good movie on import go see
mope
that was one of my favorite that was
that was one of the best movies that we
watched in the last few months i enjoyed
that
it's a true story it's a it's a it's
kind of a depressing story but
i mean it's a true story it's terrible
what happened but it was still like a
pretty entertaining movie like i said
like boogie nights it's like they
probably like horns version of the art
of self-defense
yeah movie kind of like that
all right so even though
from our point of view uh in hindsight
it seemed very obvious that chicotilo
had killed this little girl
because they found some of her blood in
the snow
like not far from his house like right
next to his house
hold on one on one fleece johnson claims
to be a shot caller i'm not sure he was
a shot caller
i think he was just a punk he was a punk
and
the [ __ ] camera crew came in and he
totally interesting [ __ ]
wild ass [ __ ] tale and they did a
whole little bit on felice johnson
and it but as far as
as far as the prison scene goes dudes
like free fleece johnson there's lots of
those
i don't think it was a shot caller he
was just pretending to be
other people probably laughed at that
[ __ ] he's just a pump
go ahead go ahead nellie says you know
you've watched enough porn when you
don't read bbc is the british
broadcasting
yeah yeah yeah probably i mean
i see we know poor people we know porn
people i see it as both things
simultaneously
like i kind of chuckle but it's like you
know florida's got a huge
mature so florida's got a huge porn they
do shoot a lot of porn down here yeah
because it's like a cheaper is yeah
california california's played out this
is the new terrace well it's like i said
it's too expensive so a lot of so you
can rent like
nice fancy houses to shoot porn and
they're like cheaper here than you can
just say yeah if you want to get into
porn and you look and you see people you
know
in them i still keep waiting for them
well
i think that's happened once or twice
but it's like we knew they are
i still keep waiting for that to happen
like one of these days i'll see the
point like
hey that's their name and then you find
out some of these people they're just
straight up hookers
yeah well that's some weird [ __ ] too
okay i've been there
it's not me i've noticed yeah but i'm
just saying it's like yeah like yeah
they're like
damn okay all right well you know i'm
not judging i'm just saying
they need money yeah i get that
is that rain i think it is yeah holy
[ __ ] where'd that come from
okay go ahead and finish start moving
back a second hold on why don't you give
me another drink while you're going to
drink here i'll make you drink
what i mean while you're leaving make
you drink
all right so as i said from our point of
view
uh you know there's blood outside his
house uh you know which
obviously looks suspicious um a witness
had seen
somebody that looked very much like
andre chicken andre chicagillo because
it was
um you know talking to the little girl
like not too long before she disappeared
uh you know because she was last seen at
a bus stop that was one thing that he
did a lot like later on was he would
pick people up from bus stops of train
stations various things like that um
now what ended up happening with this
though and this is
pretty shitty um a 25 year old kid
named alexander kravchenko
actually got picked up for the crime
now when he was a teenager he actually
had
uh served a jail sentence for rape and
murder
of another teenage girl um
so you know he wasn't a total innocent
in this situation however he had not
committed this particular crime
but he did get picked up as a suspect in
the crime
and evidently the authorities grilled
him
so severely i don't know if they beat
him i don't know something like that but
he did end up confessing to it
now he ended up getting tried for the
murder in 1979 but when he was
on the stand like at the trial he
retracted his confession and said that
they had essentially
beaten it out of him um however
uh he was still convicted he got
sentenced to 15
years which at the time was the maximum
uh
the maximum time that you could serve in
prison at that point in the soviet union
um however the victim's relatives put
pressure on the authorities
and he got retried and sentenced to
death
and was actually executed for the murder
in 1983 even though chicatilo had done
it
so like i said this guy had actually
raped and murdered well
presumably had raped him or raped and
murdered a girl when he was a teenager
but he was actually accused and executed
for this particular murder even though
chicatilo had done it so
after this as i said this was his first
known murder
um so i guess he figured out
at this stage that he was only going to
be able to obtain
sexual release by
stabbing and killing people
so it was a little while before he did
his next one though because i feel like
i think the the act of doing the first
one and
you know him leaving so much evidence
was kind of like scared him a little bit
so he was kind of able to
fend it off for a little while so the
next one didn't actually take place
until september
of 1981. now this was a
17 year old girl she was a student her
name was larissa
chachenko and he uh
again tried to rape her and was
unsuccessful
thank you very much um
and again uh the fact that he could not
maintain an erection
uh he started getting really angry about
it
and basically beat and strangled her to
death
uh he didn't have a knife with him at
this stage so maybe he hadn't actually
planned to do anything
uh but he improvised as [ __ ] up as
that is to say
so he actually ended up because one
thing that andrei chikitilo did a lot
was he would mutilate the bodies a lot
like uh postmortem he would cut off
nipples he would cut off genitals he
would gouge their eyes out he would do
things like that sometimes he would cut
off little parts of the body and like
chew on them or eat them yeah you know
right over here yeah yeah so he would do
[ __ ] like that so at this stage he
didn't have a knife with him so this
particular victim
uh he just ended up cutting her up with
like a stick that he found and
uh actually bit her all over the place
like bit
pieces of her off even leaving [ __ ]
teeth marks behind i'm sure
yeah although i guess it didn't matter
because they didn't catch him for like a
really long time
how old was he at this time now this was
in 81
so he was probably i mean he i don't
think he actually started killing people
until he was in his 40s
okay she was older yeah and and it's
interesting because when they finally
did
bring in a a psychologist on this case
like to profile
one of the first things that the
profiler said is this is an older
man from 45 to 50. so he was right about
that yeah
it's just interesting because like i
said most serial killers start doing
[ __ ] up [ __ ] when they're
teenagers usually they're in their early
20s but this guy did not start until
later
so i do feel like he tried to have a
normal life and i guess
it wasn't working out for him and once
he actually did kill somebody it just
kind of opened up the floodgates it kind
of seemed like that
you know honestly like he held off on it
exploded eventually
yeah it did actually seem like that
because as i said it's he ended up
killing like in 12 years he ended up
killing at least
52 people and probably or 56 52 to 56
people so
all right so between uh july and
december of 1982
um he killed six more people
uh these were generally children between
the ages of 9 and 19 years old
what he would do his kind of mo was that
he would approach
not usually i mean sometimes they were
prostitutes but usually they were
um kids or teenagers that were runaways
or
you know homeless kids or people who
um you know had homes but kind of rode
the trains
like a lot just like for entertainment
purposes so he would pick them up
yeah with like nothing else to do so he
would approach
that was kind of his mo was he would
approach kids in like train stations and
stuff
and he would offer them you know money
or food or
candy or something like that and
sometimes they would go with him and
then he would like take them out to the
woods try to rape them
and you know obviously it wouldn't work
and then he would kill them
um so he would usually like i said he
would stab them usually
and often would mutilate the victims
now one thing that he did and this was
kind of like a signature
on a lot of the bodies and it was one of
the things that kind of helped
uh the soviet authorities finally come
to terms with the fact that they had a
serial killer because of this particular
thing
was he would gouge their eyes out or he
would cut their eyes
they thought that it was because
um there was a very common uh
superstition in that part of the world
at that time
that a murder victim and it's not just
uh not just russia but i think in other
parts of the world it has this it's like
an eastern european thing too that a
murder victim
like it will like their eyes will kind
of like essentially take a picture
of the last thing that they look in
there and you'll see and you'll see them
yeah like it'll like the reflection so
that's like a very common superstition
in that part of the world
and it there has been speculation that
that might have been why he gouged the
eyes out
was because he was afraid that the eyes
would have like a picture of him
i don't know if that's true but that's
kind of one of the things that they i
think he's just trying to erase them
or that they're not looking at them like
i said because like i said this is a
killer that's very concerned about
you know what about being watched and
about like not
living up to people's expectations
because he feels like a failure
in pretty much every aspect of his life
i mean everything that he's done has
pretty much been
a failure at least in his eyes
so i do feel like maybe that's
more what he was doing i don't know if
he actually believed that he would get
caught because the eyeballs would like
record
an image of him yeah but he just didn't
want people looking at him maybe
that's how i think it is i think it's
probably more likely
i mean you know so
um you know as i said it's a lot of his
victims like the adult victims were all
women
uh the child victims could be either
girls or boys um
he didn't really he was kind of
opportunistic in that way
i mean i don't think he would attack
like a full-grown man obviously he never
did that
but he would go after vulnerable people
like i said young women
prostitutes runaways but if it was a kid
he didn't really care if it was
a boy or a girl it was just whoever was
there whoever was alone whoever looked
vulnerable at the time
i don't know if he attempted to rape any
of the boys
um that has never been i would think so
he might have but it's like i don't i
don't really he was lusting on him
because a serial killer
normally is killing what they're
attracted to
there's sexual quality basically from
their point of view
so he's he's a bisexual he's going after
both of them
yeah although like i said he's not
actually having sex because he can't
because he can't yeah yeah he never went
after any grown men but i think that was
probably because
now he liked boys boys and girls well i
think he didn't go after grown men
because he thought they would maybe they
would fight back kick his ass
i mean that's not a big dude he's going
after vulnerable
yeah you know he was he wasn't short but
he was
thin like he wasn't like a real like
muscular like
yeah and you know he was more like an
academic
like a shy type of dude so you know i
just go on
yeah he was going after people that were
like uh smaller
so at this stage there was like a long
um as far as they know it was a long
period where he didn't kill
anyone um so he didn't end up killing
anyone again until
june of 1983 but between june and
september of 1983 he killed
five more victims now
at this stage like i said up to this
point it's not like the authorities
weren't investigating these murders
because they were
but it took them this long because he
had started in like
you know 1978 1979 it took them this
long to finally
acknowledge that this is the same
killer because as i said because of the
eye gouging because of the
particular mutilations that they found
on a lot of the bodies
they finally came to just like look this
is a serial killer
we needed to do something about this
because for a long time they kind of
denied it they were investigating the
murders but investigating them like
separately
because they didn't really want to tell
anyone
that they thought this was one dude that
was just running around loose
so uh so they bring in a dude
um on september 6 1983
the public prosecutor the ussr he uh
formerly links together like six murders
um under the umbrella of like look this
is the same person we have a serial
killer we need to do something about it
so at this point they finally do put
together a task force they get a guy
from moscow
who gets sent there to kind of see what
he could do to help out
um and kind of lead the investigation
then they bring in
a forensic analyst viktor burakov who i
believe was the character that stephen
ray was playing in the citizen x which i
was just watching before we started
this now what they did at the beginning
which i don't know like like i said in
hindsight this seems dumb but
i can see where they're coming from uh
from the point of view of
you know before the dude was caught they
didn't know who this dude was
so what they decided to do at the
beginning
was that well this dude is obviously a
lunatic he's a sexual sadist
so they decided to start focusing on
people who were um known pedophiles
which like i said not dumb because a lot
of the uh you know victims were children
um uh known sex offenders they were
going after
gay people because yay that's just kind
of what you did back then i guess
because
back then that was all they saw gay
people as sexual deviants sure so they
say put them in the same bag as
pedophiles
um so anybody or anybody that was uh you
know mentally challenged
let's say um that was another one there
but like i said not completely
out of left field you can see i mean
going after they're just trying to cover
all babies yeah going after like
you know known sex offenders things like
that i mean that's actually a pretty
smart thing to do and that's the same
thing that we would do nowadays
um because you know people that have
done that kind of [ __ ] in the past
you know you gotta look at them if
they're doing the same kind of [ __ ] in
the future
so they were kind of like focusing on
that
now problem is that i feel like they
were under
an enormous amount of pressure to solve
these crimes they didn't really
want it leaking out to the public like i
said too much because
you know they didn't want anybody to
know that oh you know this zero kill we
can't
fix it we can't do anything about it
they didn't want to getting out to the
media they didn't want to get to the
public they especially didn't want to
getting out to the west
to make it look like they didn't know
what they were doing
or that they were behind in forensic
technology or anything
so they um what they ended up doing
unfortunately was bringing in a bunch of
you know dudes that have been convicted
of sex crimes in the past they brought
in a bunch of gay men they brought in a
bunch of other people
and essentially it seems like they kind
of
probably physically coerced them into
confessions
yeah well that's the soviet way yeah you
get out there you [ __ ]
kind of yeah yeah you did you're dealing
with you're not dealing with the [ __ ]
um
you're dealing with the police you're
not dealing with the kgb at this point
right
yeah essentially i don't think the kgb
got involved in the at this stage right
so uh you know the russian way is to
rough a [ __ ] up that's what they
did back then
yeah i mean you know everybody is state
people at this point in a communist
system you belong to the state
they want information from you they do
what they want to you
yeah that's how it is well and that's
essentially what it is so they got like
a [ __ ] ton of confessions from some of
these people because
you know allegedly that they they beat
it out of them you can beat a confession
out of anybody well they're not
and whether or not that confession is
accurate no
like i said well obviously the more you
beat somebody the less easier
that shit's gonna be it's gonna tell you
because they're just gonna tell you
whatever it was the same thing with the
[ __ ] salem witch trials and all that
kind of [ __ ] it's like you know you
torture people long enough they'll tell
you anything you want just to make it
stop
so it's like that's never going to be no
they know that though okay
a lot a lot of people will say well
that's dumb to do that they'll tell
you they knew that they knew that back
then well they just wanted
what they would do is they would go no
what they would do
is they beat somebody and then they'd
give up the information and they'd go
try to verify that information
if it didn't check out then they knew
that that person was innocent
that's what that's what the thinking was
just because you
beat that person just because you beat
the confession out of them doesn't mean
it was useless
they beat the confession out of someone
then they verified if it doesn't check
out they go
yeah he didn't do it that was yeah so he
beat the [ __ ] out of him and
they didn't care and he didn't give it
up they didn't care you're looking at it
from you're looking at it from a western
perspective
yeah well yeah i can see where i can see
where yeah their perspective was the
ends justify the means
beat the [ __ ] out of that dude then
check yeah then check then chat it's
like okay
exactly not thank you that's how they do
it yeah that's [ __ ] up i'm just saying
i i understand that
it's [ __ ] up but you know
in soviet russia you know what i mean
that's the [ __ ] way that that [ __ ]
happened you know what i mean and it's
it works and it works kind of
sort of kind of works yeah although i
will admit that at least
four people in this case three gay men
and one
prior sex offender ended up committing
suicide afterwards
yeah and because of these and tactics
and guess what
the russian cops didn't give a [ __ ]
they're like no that's just the
elimination of excess population
we didn't need them anyway they s their
deaths
saved us money yes i'm sure that's how
they
just because those are people doesn't
mean we can't kill them
this is the yeah that's the person the
west yeah this is just a person
do not project your way yeah we have
lots of people and they all cost us
money to feed
so do not project your western values on
others
that's not the way it is the way it is
in the military it's like that
not as bad u.s military but yeah it's
that same [ __ ]
methodical thing so at least four people
maybe more i don't know but at least
four people did commit suicide because
they had beaten them in confessions and
obviously they didn't do it
because the crimes continued when all of
these people were in custody
so obviously it wasn't them
so uh yeah so yeah um in
october of 1983 chicotilo killed again
this was a 19 year old girl a prostitute
and a couple months later in december
he killed a 14 year old boy a little
school student
named sergey markov uh
he didn't really wait too long before
the next ones january and february of
1984
he killed two two women in aviators park
uh so there was that and then a month
later march 24th
um he actually lured a ten-year-old boy
named dimitri
patash tashnikov
away from a kiosk in town
and in this case he was actually
i will say this about chicotilo he
didn't seem particularly concerned about
getting caught because he would pick up
kids in like broad daylight
and like people would see him like
walking down the street with this kid
well a lot of times a lot of times
that's [ __ ]
that's kind of the way to do it you hide
and play in sight
it's just like i mean it worked because
he didn't get of course over here
of course it works it's kind of like you
can take your bicycle and [ __ ] put it
up beside you on your porch in broad
daylight
you know what i mean and then [ __ ]
leave it there nobody will steal this
it's on it's in broad daylight you come
out and your [ __ ] bicycle's gone
you go that [ __ ] idiot stole my
bicycle on my front porch in broad
daylight he's gonna get
caught well where the [ __ ] is he yeah he
didn't catch him
you know i will tell you that type of
[ __ ] i had a bicycle
yeah my bicycle was stolen not from in
front of my house
but i had ridden it to the mall and
parked it outside the mall it was locked
and everything
yeah and somebody stole it while i was
in the mall
in broad daylight and broad day there
were security guards driving all around
yep nobody saw that so you go i had to
walk all the way home
you're like you're like that idiot stole
my bicycle and [ __ ] broke
daily it worked yeah well where is he he
still got my bike whoever
got your [ __ ] bike didn't he yeah
whoever's got my bike i'm still mad
about that things don't work out
that was many years ago and i'm still
mad things don't work out the way you
think they did
is he was he stupid or was he a genius
well like i said in some ways
i mean a lot of people see you that's
not good
but in a lot of ways too like if you're
committing crimes i'm not like
you know saying this is like pro tips
for anybody committing crimes or
anything
but sometimes if you're skulking around
at night
and like doing suspicious [ __ ] like
obviously i'm gonna be a lot more
suspicious if somebody's like skulking
around in my backyard
at two in the morning then i am just
somebody walking across my backyard at
like noon
right yeah that's less suspicious it's
daytime someone's trying to call
[ __ ] on me about how well torture
worked at abu ghraib
prison arbor got rid of prism torture
worked real well
it worked real well [ __ ] you tortured
people they didn't know anything you
didn't get anything
just because you tortured them doesn't
mean doesn't mean
first of all here's another thing i
gotta have pops on here terrence pops
one day we'll have terence pops on as a
[ __ ] guest
he's a [ __ ] 30-year veteran special
forces and ranger
he was in charge of abu ghraib prison
after those [ __ ] national guard guys
got kicked out
all right alba got rid was [ __ ]
haunted as [ __ ] and he'll tell you that
we're gonna do a [ __ ] apparent we'll
have him on as a paranormal guest he'll
tell you the [ __ ] i've heard that
[ __ ] though
yeah if anybody's if anything if any
place is wanted it's probably there
avogadro [ __ ] had bones everywhere
they had whole sections of that prison
that they just walled off because
people were terrified to go into it
there were [ __ ]
blood stains and [ __ ] teeth what was
going on at alba got rib made [ __ ]
what the nazis did look like [ __ ]
sunday school that's how bad abu ghrib
was
all right the iraqi people were [ __ ]
tough
you could torture an iraqi and [ __ ]
they didn't really mind
they were used to it for [ __ ]
generations when those [ __ ] in there
them damn
um national guard in there [ __ ] with
those prisoners that they got pictures
of that
embarrassed the united states they
weren't even asking those people
questions they were just hazing them
all right torture does work it works
very well it's just that in the media
they
uh they portrayed it as not working it
works
it works it works works real well a
person who doesn't know anything
will make [ __ ] up all right a person who
does know something will usually tell
usually or they [ __ ] tell stories
that eventually through a process of
ev of elimination you'll be able to find
out what the truth is
the reason why you don't want to do it
is that you have to [ __ ] torture a
lot of innocent
people to get down to the bottom of it
and in
western thinking that's wrong i kind of
think it's wrong
depending on what the stakes are uh
but in other [ __ ] in other
civilizations and other value systems
they don't care
whether or not they torture an innocent
person they just don't
they see people as like i said
excess population it depends on in china
it [ __ ] happens all the time there's
concentration camps happening in china
right now
that are about like what was going on in
[ __ ] nazi germany
and you have our tech heads dealing with
these people and people know about
it our ruling class knows all about it
they're [ __ ] got wiegers in
concentration camps and they're [ __ ]
harvesting organs off these people
and selling them to rich middle
easterners because it's halal
there's all kinds of [ __ ] happening you
don't know about yet but the history
books
will tell you later go ahead jenna
i'm just trying to keep these people
straight you got people that live in
fantasy world
there's [ __ ] going on right now that
[ __ ] would make the nazis blush
you just don't know about it yet i don't
think anything would make the nazis
blush
i don't think the [ __ ] the nazis were
into [ __ ] eliminating
eliminating [ __ ] people that they
thought were their enemies
they just didn't give a [ __ ] that's a
pretty normal [ __ ] response you're an
enemy i'm gonna kill you
um a whole idea of [ __ ] keeping
people around a harvest orgasm
off of them and weird [ __ ] making
clones and [ __ ]
although a bunch of weird [ __ ] i mean
the thing about it though it's like once
you've dehumanized someone to the
sense that you don't see them as a
fellow human anymore you can do
whatever yeah and it doesn't matter to
you anymore
you know what i'm saying i believe that
there's some weird [ __ ] that we never
thought of that's happening happened
having to do with [ __ ] cloning
and [ __ ] children and [ __ ] all
kinds of weird [ __ ] but
you go ahead i gotta go hold on take a
break hold him
you're lucky jenny you got a bladder the
size of a basketball
mine's only like the size of a softball
i know it's like he has to go
it was i laugh at him like every like i
kind of have to pee too but it's like
every time we go out to the club it's
like i laugh at him because
it seems like to me from my point of
view it seems like every 15 minutes
i gotta go take a leak i gotta i was
like what is the matter with you you're
drinking the same amount as me
but yeah so so this guy he takes this
kid who's ten years old
he takes him from like a stamp kiosk or
something like in the middle of town
it's in the middle of the day
um a bunch of people saw him though so
he takes the kid
like but after the kid turned up dead
like three days later like a bunch of
witnesses were able to come forward and
give like a description of him
to the authorities they also found when
they found the kid's
body they also found a footprint
and they also found saliva samples and
semen on the victim's clothing now this
was still 1984
so they didn't have you know dna
[ __ ] or anything like that they didn't
have anything like we have nowadays
but they were still able to blood type
which i'll get into that in a bit but
that was another thing that
maybe contributed to him like running
around loose for longer than maybe he
should have because
of the blood typing issue so we'll get
into that
so may 25th uh he kills another woman
named tatiana
petrocyan and her 11 year old daughter
svetlana he kills
both of them uh in the woods like i'm
assuming he
lured them like he usually did and ended
up killing him now
in this case normally chikatilo would
just pick up
random people that he didn't know like i
said he would go to a train station and
he would see like a kid sitting by
themselves and be like
hey i've got this neat movie here i've
got these neat stamps or i've got some
candy or something like that and he
would lure them away
um but in this case this victim
and her daughter he had actually known
them for like a really long time
um which i think as far as i can
remember this was the only
uh instance where that happened where he
actually killed somebody that he'd
actually kind of been friends with
for a long time which is kind of [ __ ]
up did you take a break at all
um yeah probably okay i'll let you take
a break because
yeah go ahead you're gonna let me go and
then you're gonna
i'll entertain you you're gonna
entertain me i'm gonna entertain these
[ __ ]
only takes you a couple seconds so what
you guys up to let me see what's going
on
tom's the old man hey i said tom's an
old man ain't that something
okay let me see
see you guys
didn't they torture my country music
okay well look
a lot of the [ __ ] that they did to
people that was kind of like
psychological pressure you wouldn't
really couldn't call that torture real
torture is when you do like physical
damage
to people um there are other
things that you can do you know what i
mean [ __ ] putting them in real cold
rooms real hot rooms [ __ ] break them
down with [ __ ] music and
psychological stuff
i'd call that more like pressure than it
would be torture
they have people that can resist
physical torture the ultimate
torture is when you're not torturing a
person you're torturing to say like a
person's
child i mean if you have a person who's
resistant to it you have to get a hold
of one of their family members and you
start torturing the family member to get
them to talk
that's usually effective you can go back
and [ __ ] this is something the united
states didn't do but
saddam did it saddam hudei and ku say
they did all that [ __ ] to people
it's easy to put up with damage that's
being done to you it's a lot harder to
put up with damage being done to say
like your daughter and she's only like
five or six you know
so they they talk or your wife you know
they rape a dude's wife and he's sitting
there watching it you know so
you can get somebody to talk you might
have to torture somebody else but
saddam and his regime were real good at
it they knew exactly what they were
doing
yo let me get in yeah go ahead
i don't have any room to like back this
chair up okay
all right there we go
all right where was i
okay so like i said uh this mother and
daughter that he killed were actually
people that he had known for quite a
long time which as i said this was uh
probably the only
time that he had done this because
normally he targeted strangers
uh july 19th uh he had already killed
three other
women between the ages of 19 and 22 and
a 13 year old boy
so as i said even though at the
beginning of his
uh rampage if you want to call it that
there was kind of like large gaps in
between his killings
just like we see in a lot of serial
killer cases it seems like as the years
go on
uh it's getting more and more numerous
like the number of victims like he just
can't
contain it anymore and i guess the fact
that he wasn't getting caught
was kind of an impetus to
doing more [ __ ] like seeing what he
could get away with
now in 1984 in the summer he actually
got fired
from his job as a supply clerk for
stealing
he stole some [ __ ] from the company and
he got fired
now he um what ended up happening oh
thank you very much mark
thank you very much let's hear your
hoorah he said
there is no hoorah hurrah says a [ __ ]
that's some [ __ ] from [ __ ] uh from
from hollywood that's that's like
that's like what ramps do it's not hura
it's
that sounds like rastan getting butt
worked cool that's the same noise that
it's the command of execution you got
the preparatory command command of
execution
that's what it is that also kind of
sounds like the noise i make before i'm
going to barf
[Laughter]
dude they're so funny making little pig
noises all the time
so uh so apparently this company that he
worked for
i guess he had stolen some [ __ ] earlier
and the accusation had been made like
several months before like back in the
winter
but i guess like the management had
asked andre to quit
and he wouldn't quit like he was being a
problem about it
um so he said that he didn't do anything
and so i guess it was like a big thing
and they ended up having to fire him
like they asked him to resign and he
wouldn't and he like made a big stink
about it
so they didn't actually end up having to
fire him however
he ended up finding another job as a
supply clerk in another company
not too long afterward it was only like
august first so it was only like a
little while that he uh
you know found a new job now pretty much
the day after
he started the new job he killed another
person
16 year old girl named natalia uh
goliskaya golov kaya holy sorry russians
i'm really sorry
so uh this was in aviators park where he
had uh murdered a couple of other
victims as well previously and less than
a week later he killed another girl a 17
year old
on the banks of the don river and then
after that
he had to go on a business trip so he
ended up going to
uh this city called tashkent which he
flew to
and while he was on that business trip
he ended up killing a couple of people
as well
um so he comes back to rostov august
15th he had killed a
another young woman and a 12 year old
girl
two weeks after that he had also killed
another 11 year old boy
who was strangled castrated and had his
eyes gouged out like many of his victims
did
um he also killed a young girl who was a
librarian her name was irina
lukenskaya and she was killed on
september
6th now
at this point what they started doing
was that
so they they kind of figured out the
authorities kind of figured out that he
was targeting
people that were at train stations like
i said like runaways or
you know transients or kids that like
rode the trains or whatever
so they started staking out some of the
train stations like some of them in
uniform
like the bigger ones they would stake
out in uniform like so they were
watching the dudes
but the smaller ones they would put
undercover agents there because what
they were
hoping would happen was that he would
see
that there was a lot of uniformed
officers at the bigger
train stations so he would go to the
smaller ones to target them and then the
undercover agents would see him so
that's kind of like what their
thinking was so
he gets observed september 13th 1984
um which was about a week after the
15th killing that he had done he
actually got seen
by an undercover detective at a train
station
or a bus station rather and he was
trying to lure a woman away from the bus
station
so the undercover agent like saw him and
took him into custody so he gets
arrested
now when they looked through his [ __ ]
like he had a briefcase or a bag or
something like that with him
they opened the thing and there's knife
there's a knife in there and there's
rope in there which
you know a little suspicious um and
when they looked into his background
they also found that he had been
investigated for
uh stealing from his former employer so
again that was very
suspicious so because of the theft
charges they're like okay well we can
hold him
for you know whatever the length period
i believe it was 10 days at that time
where you could hold them like on a
particular charge before you had to let
them go so you could like look for
evidence for other crimes
so they also found out that his physical
description
also matched uh the description of the
dude
who had been seen with uh i believe it
was ten-year-old dmitry
tashnikov back in march who had been
found dead
however because this was not this was
only circumstantial
this was not enough to hold him
indefinitely so
at this stage they were like well all we
can charge him with
is the theft from the employer
so they did actually try him for that at
this stage
and he does he was found guilty of
the theft so he gets sentenced to a year
in prison at this point
but he is let out after three months
on december 12 1984.
now at this stage a little bit later
than this october 8th 1984
um the guy who was the head of the
russian public prosecutor's office
he formally and like i said they had
been operating under the assumption that
most of these
murders were committed by the same
person but they at this stage
formally came forward and said okay 23
of these murders are linked to the same
person
and they formally dropped all the
charges against the previous people that
they had kept in custody
uh you know who a lot of whom were
mentally handicapped or
are just people that they had brought in
for various reasons they were gay or
because
they you know had done things in the
past or whatever so they actually did uh
you know
drop all the charges against those
people and said look we're there's
still somebody out there he has
committed these 23 murders
you know that all have the same
signature so we're looking for this one
particular person
now after uh arena lucanskaia was killed
on september 6th they didn't really find
any more bodies with this particular
signature like i said because there were
usually particular types of mutilations
uh eyes gouged out usually like nipples
cut off
um you know things of that nature so
they didn't find anything like that for
a long time so
for a while they thought well maybe this
guy died or maybe he moved
or something like that so the police and
rostov actually ended up sending
bulletins
um to other police agencies and other
parts of the soviet union saying hey
be on the lookout for this particular
murder or do you guys have any murders
that
meet these criteria because we think
this might be the same person and it's a
serial killer
um so they were looking for any feedback
however they didn't really get any
feedback from any of the other
uh you know any of the other towns or
any other cities that they
contacted so that was so
but so they assumed at this point
because it had been so long since
the last one that you know maybe the
dude had died or maybe he was in prison
for something else
um which was actually true because he
was in jail for theft even though he was
only in there for three months
now he gets a job so he gets out of jail
for the theft charge like i said he was
only in there for a few months
he goes to like another nearby town and
he kind of like kept on the dl for a
little
while the next murder he committed
didn't happen until the end of july
1985.
now this woman it was a young woman he
killed her
near an airport in moscow or an airport
near moscow
and then a month later he killed another
woman in
shakti and both of these uh cases were
immediately linked to the same person so
as as i said at this point even though
they were reluctant to say this was a
serial killer from the beginning
at this stage every time a new crime is
happening they are adding it to the
database
uh you know and they're assuming that
this is the same person
now in november of 1985 they get this
uh kind of new guy and he's like a
special prosecutor type
person and he's going to supervise the
investigation his name is issa castoyev
and when he comes in he kind of like
is like all right we need to you know
reinvestigate all the crimes like look
for [ __ ]
that we've missed all this other kind of
[ __ ] and then they start
um you know kind of going through known
sex offenders again and they're like
re-interviewing them
and whatnot and then they start again
patrolling all the
train stations bus stations all that
kind of stuff around rostov
and installing undercover agents again
like
looking for this person who's you know
you know attacking victims around this
area
and it is at this stage that finally
finally
they get around to bringing a
psychiatrist into the case to profile
the killer which like i said now i don't
know how true this is but the
movie citizen x um kind of went into
how the dude that was like the forensic
investigator he wanted to bring a
profiler in from the fbi
almost immediately like he's like we
need a profile of this guy
um and the fbi is way ahead of us and of
course
like the you know overarching
authorities didn't want to do that
because they said we can't ask for help
from the west that would look bad
um so but at this point finally
they're like okay maybe we should bring
a psychiatrist in on this
and profile who it is that we're looking
for
so they finally bring in this guy now he
writes this 65 page report
and he again he was pretty accurate
because he did say that the guy they
were looking for was older he said he's
between 45 and 50 years old
he said he's probably of average
intelligence
um he's probably married or had
previously previously been married which
was true
um they're like he's a sadist who can
only
achieve sexual arousal by seeing his
victims suffer
also true so he also said that because
most of the killings had occurred
on weekdays near hubs of mass
transportation
bus stations train stations and whatnot
um you know across this entire like
large area
he's like this guy is somebody that has
a job and it has something to do with
regular travel
like he travels regularly for his work
and
that he is probably tied to a production
schedule meaning that he probably picks
out people and kills them like
on work days or on work trips because
most of the murders were committed
during the work week so uh again very
accurate
so this guy was actually very accurate
so now what ended up happening though
and
you know as i said they were able to
keep it from the media for a long time
but at this point
you know the media had started to report
on it and
andre chicatilo had started following
the investigation
in the media so he actually
kind of kept his [ __ ] on the down low
for a little because he knew that they
were looking for him and i guess he like
read
the profile and thought that it sounded
kind of accurate so he thought that he
better
tone it down for a little while because
maybe they were on to him
so he actually didn't commit any murders
that they know of
uh throughout the entire year of 1986 so
he was actually able to
you know tamp down the urges for an
entire year like i said that they know
of
however in 1987 it seems like he
couldn't help himself anymore
and he ended up killing three people in
1987.
um now these he actually would wait
until he went on business trips
when he was not in rostov anymore like
he would go
on a business trip and then he would
kill someone somewhere else
so he was aware of all of the [ __ ] going
on
and knew i if i want to kill somebody i
have to do it
not and so they don't link it
necessarily they still did
but he was trying to be careful
so he actually killed a 13 year old boy
named oleg makaren makarinkov
uh in revda this was in 1987.
and in july he killed another boy and
then he killed another little boy in
leningrad in september of that year
he killed another three people in 1988
uh he killed an unidentified woman in
krasny sulein in april
and two boys one boy in may and one boy
in
july now the
woman that was killed they didn't
initially link her with this series
because she'd been killed in an
unusual way he i believe he did actually
confess to this later
so they knew that it was him um but
initially they didn't put this one in
the series because she was killed in a
weird way i guess he had like beaten her
to death with a slab of concrete
which that had not been seen in this
series
previously somebody asked how what was
this what was his body count
it's about 50 isn't it uh between 52 and
56. he confessed to 56
uh he was convicted of 52. usually when
he gets up around the numbers that hide
the offender themselves don't they don't
really remember exactly how many they
killed
a lot of times they get the faces mixed
up too and this was not a case
um you know you see in cases like uh you
know henry lee lucas or somebody like
that that
can just confess it to everything um
this guy they know that he killed this
many people
not just because he confessed but
because when they caught him
um he was convicted he was uh suspected
of 36 murders
but after he was in custody he actually
ended up uh confessing to 20 more
and showed them where the bodies were
because the bodies had not been found
yet so they know that he killed those
people because he was able to
lead them directly to where the bodies
were buried like where he had put them
so they knew that he wasn't bullshitting
probably it's 56 probably that's how
many he confessed to he was uh convicted
of 52.
so that's so that's a lot how many was
uh
gary ridgeway do we remember a lot
a lot a lot wasn't it like 60 or 70 of
them something like that now i can't
even remember we did a show but i was
like
whatever i mean this guy had a lot too
and they i think ridgeway was more
maybe correctly like i said it's not a
contest it's not right
that's not good it's like you know what
just weaseled himself into this [ __ ]
though you know what i mean yeah
he's a weasel this one was less this guy
actually chickatillo being a [ __ ] you
know he was a [ __ ]
well he wasn't he wasn't as weasely as
um
ridgeway if you were to put them side by
side
ridgeway would look like like a wimp
next to chicatillo chicatillo actually
kind of to me was
kind of comes off a little more
threatening yeah
i mean he wasn't a huge dude but i mean
he was very
he was tall but he was um
the thing about him if you were to put
him in a fight i think chickatillo could
[ __ ] take
ridgeway yeah he was bigger yeah and
like i said the thing about chickatila
was that one he was
super sadistic like he would just kind
of like you know stab and [ __ ]
uh he would just bite pieces off of you
and [ __ ] like that
um like he was a real introverted dude
but he wasn't
he wasn't like wimpy or anything like i
said i've seen pictures of him like as a
teenager and as a young man
and stuff and he looked like a pretty
big
you know uh just average looking like a
fairly good looking dude it's just that
and he look and the thing about him too
was that he got away with it so long was
because
he had a respectable job he had a wife
he had kids
he had a normal life says that ridgeway
was convicted of 49.
yeah all right all right but uh he
confessed to 71 though
yeah although do they know like
like i said this guy they're pretty sure
that he committed
at least the 52 that he was convicted
for and i would not surprise me if there
were four more that he
you know that he did confess to because
like i said he did lead them to bodies
that they didn't even know
um existed like they didn't even know
those people were missing they didn't
even know those people were dead
and he said hey i killed this person and
that person and he did that like after
he was in custody and he led them right
to the bodies
so you know and once he was in custody
and they got him to confess
he would go right to the site and he
would show them like exactly what
happened
like you know he would have one of the
cops would like be
the victim and he would show them
exactly how he had carried it out
which is kind of [ __ ] up and honestly
if you go to like murder pedia
even if you just do a google search
without safe search on
um there are many pictures of the crime
scenes of this [ __ ]
i would not advise looking at them if
you're if you don't want to see this
kind of
this kind of stuff yeah pretty bad yeah
i didn't really even like because i
don't have safe search on ever because
like i said but i was just like looking
for pictures of him is like i scroll
down a little bit i'm like oh
okay what kind of stuff was it
just people laid out on the ground yeah
just like mutilated he just mutilated
people
like i said he would gouge their eyes
out he would like cut their tits off he
would just like it's
horrible yeah yeah so are we are we at
the halfway point
we're more than happy we're more than
halfway okay okay
again again this is just what i said
i said it was like every 15 minutes he
has to run into the bathroom
but yeah all right so um
where was i okay so the the woman that
had been killed with a slab of concrete
even though
they didn't initially link it to the
investigation like after he was caught
and he confessed all the things they
actually did end up liking it like you
know
after the fact so may of 1988 he kills
another
little boy a nine-year-old uh in ukraine
now this kid that he killed um pretty
much had all the signature
[ __ ] that chicatilla usually did eyes
gouched out all the mutilations
um so they knew that it was the same
dude at that point
july 14th of that year he also killed
another kid a 15 year old boy named
yev negi oh god
[Laughter]
evgeny muratov
and this was near a uh bus station
in shakti um his body actually didn't
get found
until almost a year later but he was
also linked to the investigation because
uh the uh the mutilations on the body
were
the same now after that uh which was
as i said july 1988 it seemed like there
was a gap he didn't kill again
until march of 1989
now at this stage he killed a 16 year
old girl
and he killed her in
i guess his daughter was like full-grown
at this point and had her own
apartment but no one was living in it at
the time
so he brought the 16 year old girl to
this empty apartment and killed her in
there
and cut the body up and then put the
body parts
like in a sewer
so because the body was completely cut
up and put in the sewer which
was a little bit um different than what
he usually did
so initially this was not linked to the
same series even though
as i said later he did confess to it so
they know that this was the same killer
but as i said they didn't really because
it was a little bit of a deviation
now between may and august of 1989 he
killed
four more people um
three of these were in uh rostov and
shakti which was his normal hunting
grounds
now originally like like i said before
he was caught
uh only two of these murders were linked
to him because of the signature the
other two were not linked to him because
the signature was a little bit different
they only knew that it was him later on
after he confessed to them and like
you know told them how he had done it
january 14th 1990
he kills an 11 year old boy in shakti
march 7th he killed another boy a 10
year old
uh named miroslav makarov in rasta
botanical gardens
and eviscerated the body which was found
the following day now
like i said at this stage it's like it's
this [ __ ] has been going on since 1978.
everyone is freaking out the media knows
now that this is a serial killer
many of the bodies have been found in
the same signature on them as i said
eyes gouged out various mutilations
so they know this is the same person
there's a madman running around loose
and they're wondering the public is
wondering why
the authorities are not doing anything
to catch this [ __ ]
so um so they they're kind of like
you know under a lot of pressure to
solve it
and at this stage there's um
you know there's a lot of infighting
going on with the authorities you know
this guy's gonna get fired it's like the
shit's not gonna get caught if you
if they don't get caught you're gonna
get fired you're gonna get this then the
other
now by august 1990 uh
andre chicatilo had actually killed
three
more people april 4th he killed a 31
year old woman
in the woods uh july 28th he
lured a 13 year old boy away from a
train station in rostov
and killed him in the botanical gardens
august 14th he killed an 11 year old boy
uh again near like a beach in a place
that i'm not even going to attempt to
pronounce
so at this stage because so many more
victims have been piling up in a short
amount of time
and because so many of the victims have
been found near train stations
they decided okay what's in this one
particular route
they're like okay well here's what we're
gonna do we're just gonna like saturate
like the larger train stations with just
like police we're just gonna watch
everybody we're gonna watch everything
um so they started doing that now what
ended up happening
was that you know as i said earlier
they're just like
they just saturated the [ __ ] train
stations of bus stations and
uh with cops and anybody they said any
adult
man that is in the company of a woman or
a child
you stop them and you question them i
don't care what they look like i don't
care what they're doing
you just stop them look for their look
at their papers ask them what they're
doing
ask them who this person is so they were
going kind of like
all out like to catch this dude traffic
must not have been that bad
i don't know every man with a child or
well that was the goal i don't know if
they actually ended up doing that or not
because that seems like a little
unrealistic
it's like [ __ ] almost everybody well
yeah that'd be everybody like every
grown man that was with a woman or a
child
yeah i you know if you were with a woman
and a child
although i'm gonna say that's not
because he did actually kill a mom and
daughter probably didn't actually happen
that way it probably happened what
what probably happened is anybody who
looked suspicious
who was with a man or a child because
you could tell
the body language whether or not they
were comfortable yeah if you look shifty
yeah that's what they were talking about
yeah so they put this operation into
effect
uh october 27th 1990. so
three days after that they find another
body a 16 year old boy named vadim
gramov and
this is uh near another train station
now he had actually been dead for 10
days um so he had actually been killed
prior to this new thing that they were
doing where they were like staking out
all the train stations
now on the same day that the body was
found october 30th
uh andre actually lured another 16 year
old boy named victor
tashenko off of a train at another
station
and killed him in a nearby forest so
this dude was
i mean he had to have known that
the cops were [ __ ] crawling all over
every bus and train station
in this area and he was still doing it
anyway
he was operating within an area that he
was that he was real
um uh familiar with familiar with and
very confident
it was like an area it was an area that
[ __ ] he knew very well
so he could say oh they're not here now
[ __ ] that's what he's doing
or he was confident in his ability to
look like a normal
person yeah i mean how normal could you
look though like a grown man
like going up to a 16 year old kid and
being like hey kid
want some candy the funny thing is about
the soviet union during this era
is that it was kind of a sleepy place
you're not talking about a real
upbeat [ __ ] thriving area everything
is kind of [ __ ] spread out over a
larger area
everything is kind of [ __ ] uh uh
kind of [ __ ] institutionalized in a
certain way yeah it's kind of like being
on a damn military base that's the way
the soviet union was like
so there was a lot of areas that were
slow
because yeah neighborhoods didn't exist
based on how [ __ ] economically viable
they were they existed based on what the
government wanted
so there'd be a lot of areas that would
be
have [ __ ] they're kind of built up
and didn't have hardly have any traffic
and that's that's where that's where
he's operating you know what i mean he's
operating in a [ __ ]
in a [ __ ] chilled out [ __ ] kind of
slow sleepy this must have been i mean
this was still
i mean 1990 that was the year i
graduated high school but i mean now
that i think it was a long
time ago yeah it was a long time ago and
so
and it and you know i'm not from the
soviet union so i don't know what it was
like at that
point supposed to be boring but it was
kind of like
apparently he wasn't having too much
trouble yeah
approaching teenagers or
young women and being like hey i've got
some food or i've got this that and the
other thing
and why don't you come with me and some
people were
after i got out of the army and moved to
boston i hung out with a [ __ ] russian
guy who has been
[ __ ] hanging out man his name was
vadim vadim
was his name he's back he's in germany
now
and he was a [ __ ] russian goth guy
same
same age as me he was ex-military too
had long [ __ ] black hair
and me and him were a [ __ ] killer
wingman team in the club
but dean was the [ __ ] and he
he looked like antonio banderas like a
russian antonio
that's exactly who i was pictured that's
what it looked like look like a russian
interview
and uh he said that the soviet union was
boring
that that's right i've heard it's just
real boring yeah and he was [ __ ]
in boston having a time of his life very
popular with the women
and he was a creation of a stripper when
he first showed up in the united states
he was dorky
and he's and [ __ ] he moved in with a
stripper who [ __ ] just loved him
and grew his hair out and he [ __ ]
became a guy
she educated him she created a [ __ ]
monster
that's what happened because he broke up
with her and he started hanging out with
me
and i was single at that time we were
[ __ ] [ __ ] up oh i guess like an
american
i can imagine how that went an
ex-american soldier
infantry soldier and an ex-russian
infantry soldier
in the goth scene in the [ __ ] 90s in
the [ __ ] night
we're getting in 95. see people people
always talking about the [ __ ]
russians this the russians that you know
the [ __ ] you're talking about i was
[ __ ] partying with the russians
worked with the [ __ ] russians when i
was in the service at the end part of
the russians
they're they're just good dudes you know
just good dudes well like i said
most people around the world are pretty
similar and uh
he was just a regular allergist right
yeah
he told me that the soviet union was was
boring
that's it that's the main problem with
it
uh they didn't have cool clothes
uh it was if to get cool music was
always western music and had to get it
in the underground
you couldn't really show off [ __ ] any
subculture [ __ ]
that you knew about yeah you kind of had
to keep it low
uh although they were all into it even
like the rest
of it like you know you're in the
russian army and they [ __ ] knew
everything about [ __ ] the beatles
[ __ ] the rolling stones
[ __ ] guns and roses they knew all
that [ __ ]
it's just that they kind of kept it low
yeah i believe it
yeah i mean you know that's the cool
[ __ ] yeah
back in those days that was the cool
[ __ ] so
but he just said it was boring i can't
do that
yeah it's just kind of boring yeah and i
kind of feel like that might have been
how chicatilo got away with his [ __ ] for
so long because
he just came across as just like a
normal
you know he was a communist party dude
he was like a good he had a job he had a
wife he had
kids um he just looked like a regular
guy and i mean the fact that he was just
going to these train stations when he
was on business trips and just picking
up random people and taking them in the
woods and killing them
it just really and like i said i feel
like there was a
misperception at the time that maybe
there wasn't um that maybe they didn't
have
serial killers in the soviet union yeah
i think they did it was probably like
a thing where they didn't really want
that [ __ ] getting out but
i think there was a perception that
serial killers
that that was like a decadent western
thing
yeah because we had so many um
which i don't know a true that is i
don't know how many they had in the
soviet union because
of the uh you know the way that they
didn't like
let information about that [ __ ] leak out
according to vadim it was just this
during his time this is the 90s we're
talking about yeah
he said it was like a [ __ ] it was a
developing nation and it was boring you
knew about with the outside world but it
did they didn't have it yeah yeah and it
was like everything was a pain in the
ass
yeah you couldn't get a hold of it yeah
and um
in the mid 90s [ __ ] but the soviet
union fell i think in 90 i think it's 91
is when it fell
um as far as i remember yeah and then
like
late 80s you just couldn't get a hold of
it and [ __ ] and then like after the
soviet union felt it was like an
apocalypse that went on for a long time
and that's why he got out of there
because it was just like the end of the
world
and a lot of people were dying and [ __ ]
looking
for lack of medicine and money and
taking dangerous jobs and
girls were disappearing and stuff
because they would just get involved in
[ __ ]
international sex trade and [ __ ] with
the middle east and
a lot of bad [ __ ] happened it was like
the russian apocalypse or the end of the
world
um i asked him i said why you know when
i i talked to him last uh i guess it was
about six months ago you know
you know i hadn't seen him in a while
and talked to him a long time and i said
i thought you'd be back in russia now
and he's like no i'm in germany
and i said why don't you go back there
you know and he goes it's still not
really kind of
quite cool enough that's not cool enough
yeah
that's really not quite cool enough so
but uh so he's just in germany what used
to be eastern germany that's where he's
at now
yeah yeah man remember like back in the
old days yeah
it hasn't been like like divided germany
a long time it's so weird
i know we're from another era he's
[ __ ] young kids
sometimes i know sometimes it seems like
that like i don't feel like an old
person necessarily but
yeah when i think about that kind of
[ __ ] like oh yeah we remember
like so we remember divided germany we
remember all that yeah
and it's like it's probably people from
there don't even remember that
yeah because it was such a long time ago
so
yeah so the next person he killed like i
said at this stage
it seems like uh you know he's kind of
like escalated all the [ __ ] so he kills
another person
in uh early november of 1990 he kills uh
this 22 year old woman named
sveta korostik and this was uh in the
woods near another
train station now at this stage
as i said a lot of these train and bus
stations had been kind of staked out by
the authorities so um
this time he got seen so
he went with this woman and he killed
her in the woods
now when he was coming out of the woods
and he was coming back to the station
um an officer saw him coming
out of the woods and he was coming back
to the station and he
like went up to like a well and he
washed his hands in his face
and as he was coming closer to the
station the officer noticed that he had
um like a little smear of something on
his face like that was red
and that he also had grass and like dirt
stains on the elbows of his coat and the
officer thought that that looked a
little suspicious which it would
because like i said they were looking
for a serial killer at this stage
and he noted that well there was like a
thing where
i guess collecting wild mushrooms was
kind of popular
at the time i don't know if it is
anymore but at the time it was very like
popular for people to go off and like
try to find mushrooms in the woods and
he's like well this guy didn't look like
he was looking for mushrooms he wasn't
dressed right
um he had a different kind of bag than
people that would
look for mushrooms would normally have
so they thought it was
fishy so this cop stopped him
and he looked at his papers however
he didn't really have enough to hold him
on so he couldn't really keep him
because he's like well
just looking kind of fishy isn't enough
to retain somebody
you know even in soviet union so
he actually kind of came back so he's
like all he could do he let the dude go
after he kind of like looked at his
papers but then he came back to
the police station and he noted the
dude's name down
andre chicatilo and he wrote it down and
he kind of said like what was
unusual and what had made him stop him
that day
now the body of the uh
the kid that andre had killed at that
point wasn't found until
okay november 13th what i want to show
you guys some
this is about deemed now
that's what he looks like now he's cute
yeah back in the day he had long black
hair and [ __ ] that was him
see if he's got some more golf pictures
back when we're [ __ ] hanging out
see he lives oh he's actually living in
berlin now
living in berlin germany all right i've
never been to berlin but i've always
wanted to go
i've heard it was a rad place anybody
live in berlin can tell me if it's a rad
place
i mean it used to be a rad place back in
the day because i feel like a lot of
a lot of musicians i was into like lived
there for a time
and really liked it sounded cool
trying to see if i could he doesn't have
any old photographs from back in the day
ian b says there's his daughter now what
was [ __ ]
you [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up
yeah that dude was a [ __ ] he was a
beast he was beast back in the day
okay he looks a little bit like david
cronenberg yeah a little bit yeah
i mean when david kernenberg was really
young yeah that's my russian brother
enb says i don't understand how these
serial killers enjoy killing
i don't get that either but i think
that's kind of why i find them
fascinating because they seem so
alien like why i don't understand like
how you would get
enjoyment out of
hurting another like an innocent person
like i can see
hurting someone that was an [ __ ] that
kind of deserved it
like i get that yeah i can only
understand it through hate
and fighting that's what i mean i get
that yeah like if somebody did some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] or like somebody
like i said if somebody didn't think to
you or somebody didn't think that pookie
or something like that i can't
understand like one to kill and eat that
person
they're doing but just like a random
person that didn't do anything to you
why
would that i don't yeah i don't get into
this [ __ ]
killing people for sexual gratification
killing a helpless person who's begging
for sexual
gratification you got to be some [ __ ]
real
insecure [ __ ] to get off on that
spirit that's it that's like a terrible
well like i said i think that's kind of
why i find them fascinating it's just
because they're so
alien to my mindset like i don't
understand why you would ever get
enjoyment out of that i said dude i
can't even like step
on a bug i feel bad
just killing like i don't like i said
and i've said this on the show before
except for cockroaches because [ __ ] them
but it's like i can't even kill
a spider for [ __ ] sake i can't even
kill a spider
oh i smashed a spider in a [ __ ]
heartbeat and i and i get mad at you
about that because it's a spider
i don't like spiders man [ __ ] they're
just crazy i like spiders yeah
i like spiders because they eat well
ashes i can understand it coming from
but
it's not for me it's not spiders just
snakes i don't like people they kill
snakes for nothing no i don't even like
i
really don't like people snakes are
awesome yeah even though
snakes poisonous snakes i've caught a
lot of them let them go
coral snakes rattlesnakes diamondback
rabbits
get into our house actually pookie
brought a baby snake
into our house one day yeah she was so
proud
yeah uh yeah we we rescued it
but i don't understand like well because
like i said my grandmother used to like
kill
snakes just just because they were in
her yeah and she used to kind of said i
think someone said no
no no it's like don't yeah i don't
you know i don't know i've i've always
had like pets that were reptiles like
i've always had lizards and stuff like
that so
it bothers me that people are so
weirded out by reptiles i mean i think
they're adorable
yeah don't hurt reptiles you guys i mean
seriously other than cockroaches which
[ __ ] them like i said i can't even
i can't kill bees i can't kill spiders i
can't kill
anything like that so i can't imagine
enjoying killing a person
that didn't do anything yeah i can't
imagine getting any kind of um
satisfaction of that i can't imagine
like i said i
understand if if somebody did something
really [ __ ] up or they did something
really horrible to you i get that
killing somebody for sexual motives for
sexual reasons yeah why
it's like i don't understand i don't
understand it's like a perversion it's a
it's an evil yeah it's like i don't
understand people who's like
it's it's very much an outlier this is
at an extreme
end of [ __ ] human behavior and i
think that's why a lot of people are
fascinated with them and that's kind of
what makes me feel better about it
because i
i think that people feel like people
that are fascinated with serial killers
they're like oh that's messed up and
everything i don't think it's messed up
i think that the fact that people are
fascinated with them
is good because the fact that people are
fascinated with them means that they're
unusual and people find that [ __ ]
strange and it's interesting because
it's strange
and that's good because if everybody
thought like that
then no one would think it was strange
which would be really worrying
yeah you know i'm just saying you're all
right
yeah okay i could use another break i'm
gonna get it to get another break in a
minute you gotta go get another drink i
need a drink too yeah
how much is that how much is left you
can take what i don't know how we doing
you can take one if you want to okay
hold on
me and dennis will you and dennis go to
[ __ ] chill i can't do dennis's voice
all right so uh where was i so yeah like
i said
so they find um this kid's body
now when they find the body they
go back and they're like okay well who
are all the people that you stopped on
this particular day by this particular
train station like near where we found
the body
so one of the names that came up was
andre chicatillo's
name so he was kind of like
went not necessarily on top of the list
but in one of the top of the list
because
he had been questioned in 1984
for a similar type of crime and it also
been placed on the
list in 1987 of suspects
of this crime so he kind of went to like
the top tier of like people they were
worried about
now what they did um they started like
looking into andrei chicatilu's
background
and when they did that they noticed that
um when they looked into where he was at
particular times they noticed that he
was in
a lot of the towns where a lot of these
bodies turned up
at the times when these bodies were
would have had to have been murdered
which they found was very suspicious
also um they kind of looked into
his uh teaching days from you know
back in the old times and uh found out
that he had been fired because of his
uh the allegations of molestation
against students
and they thought that was suspicious as
well
so because of all of these things they
decided that there was enough evidence
to put him
under surveillance so
november 14th they put him under
surveillance
and what they noticed was that when they
were watching him
um he very often would be at a train
station
and he would approach either kids or
young women who were alone and he would
go up to them at a train station or a
bus station and he would
uh you know strike up a conversation
and um if that
woman or that child would talk to him a
minute and then they would take off or
whatever
then he would wait a couple minutes and
then he would approach
someone else like another kid or another
woman by themselves and engage them in
conversation as well
which the police found again very
suspicious
as you would so they kept
in mudder surveillance for six days
um november 20th uh you know after the
six days of surveillance
uh they saw that andre had left his
house
and he had this big uh flask
it was either full of beer or it was
going to be
filled with beer at some point because
that was one thing that he used to like
lure people in like hey i've got alcohol
or hey i've got money hey i've got candy
whatever
so what he did was he filled this with
up with beer he would go around
the town the bus station the train
station
and he would go up to kids or young
women and he would be like hey i have
alcohol
you know hey come with me or whatever so
again they were watching him and it
seemed really suspicious
so at this point they're like okay well
we have enough
um you know evidence to at least bring
him in on this charge
after six days so he comes out of a cafe
and four officers who were in plain
clothes
ended up taking him into custody
now when they first brought andre into
custody
he initially insisted that he was
innocent he hadn't done anything
wrong he's like look i've been arrested
for something similar in 1984
uh for the same series and they didn't
find anything
and you know you guys are just picking
on me whatever
so at this stage they do a strip search
of him now when they do a strip search
they find that one of his fingers
had a wound on it and the wound that
they found on his finger
appeared to be a human bite
mark and they presumed
that one of his victims which was a 16
year old teenage boy
had bitten him during the course of him
like
kidnapping and attacking this boy so
this was yet another
you know yet more evidence oh my
goodness oh man
man she was strong that [ __ ] was strong
it's okay i got it i got this [ __ ] under
control don't worry don't worry people
i have a feeling that you don't actually
oh man
[Laughter]
damn so as i said when they searched
them they
they found a bite mark and they said
okay well you know the last victim that
they found
you know the teenage boy it did look
like from the state of the body that it
looked like this particular victim had
uh mightily struggled against his
attacker and it's entirely possible that
he had bitten his attacker in the course
of the struggle
so it does look like this is more more
this is looking like
uh our man and they also found it very
suspicious that even though
andre had this bite on his finger and
apparently the victim had bitten a
fingernail off
there was like a huge i mean it was a
big wound
and uh they couldn't find any medical
records that andre had ever gone to a
hospital to see about this wound so they
thought that was also very suspicious
so um so that was another thing that
kind of led them to believe that maybe
they had finally
uh got their man they searched through
his belongings
found they uh they also found a folding
knife
in his possession when they caught him
so
they put him in a cell at the kgb
headquarters in rostov
and they put him in there with a police
informant
now this guy was supposed to like you
know as
as they do they're supposed to like he's
supposed to talk to the guy yeah
and get him to like confess to something
so they start formally questioning him
questioning him on
the 21st november this is 1989 i believe
or 1990 rather so
what they were going to do was that
they figured that the best way to go
about this was
to approach him in a way that
could let him kind of offload the guilt
for the [ __ ] like by saying
that maybe you're crazy and
so maybe we can get you some help you're
trying to get me please guilty
right that's kind of what they were
trying to do like they were trying to
get him to like confess like to an
insanity
so that was actually probably a smart
thing yeah
um so that's kind of how they approached
it they wanted to take the easy path
they want to give an easy way out
right yeah um because they knew that
they didn't have a lot of physical
evidence because what i neglected to
mention before
um and i will kind of go into it now was
that they did actually do
they got a blood type from some of the
semen samples
from some of the because like i said
this happened in the early 80s so
you couldn't there was no dna there was
nothing like that but you could
establish a blood type from the semen
sample
however the problem was that
the semen samples that they got from the
crime scenes
indicated that the blood type of the
killer
was a b look who it is oh my goodness
pookie came in
you were sleeping your ass off most of
the time yeah she's been napping
all day what's up okay she's asking me
to go outside
let's go outside do you want to go
outside poking come here
come here do you want to be on the show
go ahead yeah yeah
so so it looked like the blood type was
a b
problem was when they took a blood
sample from
andre chicatilo blood type was a
so a lot of times they were like well he
doesn't match so he's not the killer
what they didn't find out until later on
was that andre chicatillo is what they
call it's a very rare thing called a
non-secretor
that means that your blood type cannot
be determined
from your semen or your saliva or
anything like that it only be from the
blood
right so since they didn't have a blood
sample
from the crime scenes they only had
semen and saliva
which indicated a different blood type
then the blood type seemed like it was
not a match
even though it was indeed from the same
dude like i said this is a very rare
thing but they do know about it it does
happen
from time to time and that was indeed
what happened in this case so i'm not
going to blame the authorities in this
case because
that was something that was not real
well known at the time
that you could actually have a thing
where someone's semen and someone's
blood
indicated different blood types so it
looked like it wasn't the same person
even though it was
indeed the same person so as i said they
were trying to
get andre to confess to the [ __ ] by
kind of encouraging him that maybe
you'll be able to get off in an insanity
defense
so that's kind of what they were hoping
to do and like i said it seemed like a
smart thing to do because it did end up
kind of working out so at this stage
they didn't have like i said they didn't
have a lot of physical evidence
um so they were really pushing to get a
confession because they said this is
kind of the only thing that's going to
like clench the case
we don't have a lot of other physical
evidence otherwise and under soviet law
at that time you could only
keep the person in custody for 10 days
without charging them um after that you
had to let them go so they were kind of
like
you know they were kind of on a time
constraint at this stage
now so at first when they start
questioning
andrei chicotillo about the crimes he's
denying denying denying tonight
now he did readily admit that he had
molested
his students when he was a teacher so he
wasn't
embarrassed about that apparently
because he very readily
confessed to doing that um he also
he would write a bunch of stuff for like
the psychiatrist like i said that
produced the
uh you know the profile about him and he
actually asked andre to write some
essays
for him now even though in these essays
it did seem like he was denying the
murders like some of the stuff that he
said
was um led them to believe that he
probably did do them like the way that
he worded
uh certain things
so what they ended up doing
so they bring in the psychiatrist uh to
help question him as well
and apparently whatever the psychiatrist
did
like during the questioning was really
effective
because even though andre had been
denying committing the murders
after only two hours with the
psychiatrist he broke down
and confessed to 36 murders
the same ones that had all been uh
linked to the same killer
found his soft spot somehow i guess he
did well like i said
psychiatrist man that's like you know
people [ __ ] on them but they
they know what they're doing this one
earned their money apparently
now they actually had had two other
cases that they had attributed to him
that he denied committing so that might
have been another person i'm not really
sure but he did readily admit to
uh you know after the two hours of
interrogation he didn't readily admit
these
36 murders not only that but he came
forward too
and said hey not only those 36 i've also
committed these 20 more
and hey do you want to know where the
bodies are because i will show you
so he did actually end up like i said it
wasn't [ __ ] it wasn't some henry
lucas [ __ ] because he did actually lead
them to
these uh burial sites of 20 more
well once you confess to 30 confessing
to 26
yeah you know what's the difference so
they did actually he did actually lead
them to
several that they hadn't even found like
bodies that they hadn't even found
he knew the number off the top of his
head evidently
yeah see this is another thing and we
talked about this on the gary ridgeway
show we've talked about this on serial
killers that have these really like
alarmingly high body counts
it's like you would think like i can
barely remember
what i had for breakfast this morning
yeah how
like if you've killed 56 people
yeah for example over 12 years yeah
how would you remember the details i
don't understand how you would remember
the details and do you care
at a certain point that's what i mean
it's like how many of them are working
like
i forget [ __ ] that i give a [ __ ] about
right
like you know what i mean so i would
think
if you're a serial killer i'm just
extrapolating i'm not a serial killer i
don't think that way
but it's like if you were a serial
killer and you just see other people as
objects for your own edification yeah
um how do you remember yeah
how many of them there were how many of
them there were what their names were
and where they're
buried how do you remember that and do
you bother keeping count
i would think no i would think that too
but it's like i guess i
might be mistaken i would think that i
would think that you wouldn't give a
[ __ ]
how many of them you killed that's what
i i mean i would think that but
i think so too and then like after
[ __ ] 10 or 15 of them
you're not even keeping count you're
just you're just living your life
living your life killing people like you
do you're not really counting them
i mean i the i think about it can you ca
i can't count how many women i had sex
with
because they don't keep counting because
there were so many no no
yeah well yeah it's just normal [ __ ] it
gets to a point where
well it's not something that you think
about yeah i'm thinking about time
because it's not
super important right it's not like i'm
saying i'm a hoe
i'm just saying that i don't count them
because that wasn't the priority it was
just normal
life it was just normal [ __ ] that normal
life yeah you know what i mean i feel
like
and i would think that because this is
their sexual orientation
are they counting i would think that
maybe btk would be count
dennis dennis would probably count the
thing about because i think he was lucky
he felt himself lucky to have it have a
sexual experience the thing about btk
and i think there's
that there are some similarities with
this guy as well
i feel like what happens is the reason
that um
dennis raider remembered all this [ __ ]
and maybe the reason that um
andre uh chicateela remembered this [ __ ]
as well
was that because he remembered it
because he would
bring it back in his head and like it
was a
you know it was a conquest it was a
source of you know
sexual power it was something that he
would fantasize about later
so he remembered it later on as he would
like bring it back in his head so maybe
that's why they remember
yeah better than others because it's
like i feel like
i don't know man if somebody like asked
me hey i don't even remember
like i said i've written like
i've spent months and months like
writing a short story or a novel or
something like that for example
and then like a couple years later i
read it and i don't remember like
writing that
yeah so it's like the the fact that
people can kill
someone read what mobile problems said
he's got a good point
some of them probably keep little
journals and notes like it's they
probably do
like like a 12 year old well i think
yes btk did that kind of [ __ ] because
the thing about
dennis rader and i think this might
apply in this situation as well
is that he spent so much time
fantasizing and planning
and he was such a big deal every detail
of what he was going to do like it was a
source of pleasure to him
just to plan even if he didn't do it it
was like a big source of like he would
make all these notes and like
diagrams and all this kind of [ __ ] so i
feel like that was a similar kind of
situation
it is not a normal sexuality what we're
talking about obviously
it's it's it's more childlike
yeah what they're saying yeah they're
constantly thinking about how many boys
they kissed
that's exactly what this pro you got i
think i think it's an
infantile yeah i think he nailed that
it's an infantile
um kind of way to go about it because
because adults don't keep score
normal adult people have too many other
things going on
in their life to give a [ __ ] it's like
dude i am too upset
like every day it's like i i you know i
just take every one day at a time it's
like i have so many things to do it's
like oh [ __ ] i gotta do laundry today i
gotta do this on the other thing
it's like i can't remember right all of
that crap
everything they have right i just can't
it's not important
right and it's like especially stuff you
were just going with the ebb and flow
ten years ago i don't remember anything
that happened 10 years ago a normal
person just goes with the normal ebb and
flow of daily life
right some things happen some things
don't happen you don't really you don't
you're just dealing with it you don't
really care
right because you have like more
immediate concerns
right i have things that i have to do
today it's like i can't
and like i said i'm not saying that 10
years ago that wasn't important in my
life i'm just saying i don't really
remember much about
what happened back then like if somebody
asked me hey what were you doing on this
day 10 years ago
i would not be able to tell you there's
like no [ __ ] way yeah
so but i feel like that's kind of part
of the fascination or part of the
pathology
is that their whole lives are so
oriented around this one thing
that that's that it's like an obsession
for them
and the the fact that they do remember
all these details the fact that this
dude
could not only confess to these 36
murders but also confess hey there's
these 20 other ones that you guys don't
even know about and here are the bodies
and he led them to where the bodies were
he remembered
and that just blows my [ __ ] mind
it blows my [ __ ] mind but like i said
that's why i'm not
thankfully that's why i'm not a serial
killer because i don't my
brain doesn't work it's got it right
it's it's a juvenile mindset
it is it it is very i think it's very
stunted
right yeah i think that's exactly what
it is they're not well developed
and just any little old thing is a big
deal to them
yeah they're making their [ __ ] edge
lords right there's a this entire
construction that they built around it
and i mean even though i feel like in a
lot of ways chicatilo
was a lot less organized than someone
like dennis
raider was i mean dennis raider um you
know as he can probably tell us because
there he is right there
yeah i'm keeping out of this
you know extensive notebooks and he was
very um
that was kind of like his whole second
life like and he had like diagrams and
everything like so he was that was like
his whole
thing oh i'm an artist i'm an artist
about this
man a real man has to keep records
that's kind of that's yeah now i feel
like chikatilo was more
like i said he was more opportunistic
in the sense that you people some
sort of for maximum look at it
little bald ass heads i know
i'm just gonna rub it that's good that's
a good action figure sophie sent that
did you
she did yeah just look hilarious i know
it's like i went to that site to like
look at i was like oh my god they have a
richard ramirez one they have like so
many other ones
that's so messed up but it's like i
don't know i find them amazing
because like i said serial killers i
feel like
people that are terrible like that i
feel like in a lot of ways we should
probably just
i'm not downplaying like um
the [ __ ] they did to the victims because
obviously that's horrific no but you
shouldn't but
yes mock them yeah like because they
hate that
yeah i i feel like you should always
like serial killers you've got to make
horrible people so make them they should
become a meme
yeah just make fun of them because they
would hate that more than anything
they want to be badasses they want to be
scary
don't give them that right don't give
them that's not what they that and
that's not what they are
exactly they're not scary don't give
them they're [ __ ] pitiful yeah
and like i said i'm not downplaying the
victims at all because like i said
that's horrible and if that happened to
someone i love that would be like
horrible but don't
don't buy into like what they want like
the narrative that they want to like
they're monstrous [ __ ] but
they're not powerful and they're not
[ __ ]
strong they always kill a person much
weaker than them
it's not a challenge for them right
and like i said you're not talking about
and not talking about a david and
goliath situation
yeah you're not talking about [ __ ]
[ __ ]
slaying dragons and [ __ ] you're talking
about somebody who's punching down
bigger than a [ __ ] exactly
exactly and that's why
that's why i talk about them i find them
psychologically fascinating but also i
think that they should
be denigrated and made fun of yeah
because and mostly because i know that
they would hate that because that's not
what they want
they want to be seen as powerful they
want to be seen as demonic and scary
people just don't give them that don't
give them that a lot of people want me
to channel
thank you nico they want me to channel
thank you very much [ __ ]
show us some of them goddamn flashbacks
they want us to they want me to channel
[ __ ] um
dennis because dennis is best remembered
as a meme
you know what i'm talking about yeah
he's a meme yeah well well
because that's the way he was horrible
there was nothing really
deeper to him than that right as much as
he
tried to my they try to make themselves
out
to be more than they are i'm running my
projects and i'm gonna
you know which to me like i said i was
like dead [ __ ] i'm gonna take pictures
of it right that's how they did because
that's how ridiculous
that's how ridiculous but it also makes
me
want to mock them even more because i
know how much they don't like it
i'm gonna put on some pantyhose put on
some panties and take a picture of
myself
right yeah that's [ __ ] what he was
that's what that's all it is
you know put on some garters and take a
picture of myself and the thing about it
it's like if dudes down in the grave and
and not kill anyone then hey knock
yourself
out i'm not judging that is not what
this when you do this
and then you kill people too then i will
absolutely mock you for that the
[ __ ] that we know that are
going to put on [ __ ] garter belts are
going to do that [ __ ] because it's a
[ __ ] lark
and they're going to be talking about
the [ __ ] well they'll go
jumping through the time warp they're in
the middle of the club and they're going
to be [ __ ]
dancing they're not ashamed no no don't
put a game to that [ __ ] no they're
getting if you're gonna do that rocky
horror picture
show you know thank you hayden thank you
thank you show us some of those flash
bulbs
show us the most possible because this
is the rocky horror picture show that's
a [ __ ]
totally different [ __ ] deal than what
dennis was up to
yeah totally there dennis saw himself as
a man i'm a real man
yeah that's [ __ ] when he was talking
that's the angle he was well and there's
your problem right yeah yeah
because i feel like now see this is like
i said this is another thing these were
bad people and you know i'm a good
person and
you know but i had the x factor you know
yeah yeah
and and you know yeah yeah you might
have to put on
a pair of stockings and kill a [ __ ] and
take a picture of her at the church
that's a weird [ __ ] man i'm gonna take
you to the church and
lay down yeah this is another thing
let's get into this a little bit because
this
this is still relevant to the case of
chicatilo because
i feel like the perception
the cultural perception let's say of
masculinity
is something that maybe not nowadays so
much but it
used to feed into uh
the pathology of people that became
serial killers
yeah i mean what's that
that's nico gilbert nico act matter of
fact nico's getting shirts from us
isn't he i believe so isn't nico [ __ ]
um
i don't know probably i have to look
like i said i got the records right
okay just saying what's up nico he's
he's a regular
i remember that you know and then hayden
santos
that's a new guy hayden yeah yeah that's
a new guy thank you very much hayden
not that new but like yeah okay yeah
but so i feel like and as i said it's
kind of relevant in the case of btk it's
kind of relevant in the case of um
android chicatilo
because you're a little
okay so i feel like there's kind of a
thing where
people's perception of what masculinity
should be um you know in btk's case
where
you have to be a family man you have to
be a christian you have to be this that
and the other
in chicatilo's case you have to be again
a family man you have to be able to get
it up you have to you know
you know have children you have to do
the things that a man should do
and their failure to meet these
criteria is kind of what
drove them to becoming serial killers
and i'm not saying that like
obviously other people didn't meet those
criteria but
dealt with it in a healthier way than
obviously going out and killing random
people
because not a lot of people do that but
let me tell you
guys something well and i think that
shame is a thing too because btk had a
thing where he had this whole
other life i mean secret life these were
tilo had a thing
too where he was kind of like had a
whole separate life from his
wife and his children these were men
from a prior generation and in chicago's
[ __ ]
situation he was a man from the soviet
union was a totally different
civilization it had different [ __ ]
you know i mean had different cultural
values and everything
not all men are the same they're just
not well not all
anybody is yeah people are different
everybody i mean if you were to look
at [ __ ] my life on paper
i fulfilled all that traditional a lot
of that for traditional
manly [ __ ] i don't really consider that
to be everything there is about me and
there's a lot of dudes that i respect
like a [ __ ] that didn't do what
i did
that i give them just for there's a lot
of different kinds of men
well there's a lot of just a lot of
stuff you got to you got
[ __ ] george s paton [ __ ] i
mean that that i respect
but then you got guys like [ __ ]
like like [ __ ] wagner you know i'm
talking about and guys like [ __ ]
wolfgang amadeus mozart amadeus
yeah you got guys like that now you got
guys like eddie van halen there's a lot
of different kind of guys
yeah yeah i mean there's a lot of
different types of ways to make it
so i don't really understand what is up
with these dudes
i think the problem in general is
rigidity yeah too [ __ ] rigid and
that's just not [ __ ] wrong that's not
with men that's with everybody it's like
you can't have
like a rigid conception of people
should be like this yeah because exactly
that's just not the way to approach
because everybody's different everybody
has their own controversy now you
believe that there should be a tendency
you know what i mean
like men should tend towards a certain
i don't even know if i'd go that far i
believe most of them should because that
helps a civilization run smoothly
but having outliers that talented
that's acceptable too you know i'm
talking about
and you never well the thing about it
and i kind of approach this every time i
meet somebody i don't know
what that person has gone through i
don't know what that person has to offer
i don't know was that i don't know
so it's like you can't just right off
the bat whatever they look like or
whatever they sound like or whatever you
can't like judge that person it's like
oh that person is
useless or that person is this that and
the other thing because you don't know
that person
you don't know what they have to offer
there are many many different ways
and we're talking about men there are
many different ways to be a man
but you always want to be a useful man
you know i'm talking about everybody
wants to be useful everyone
to mankind you have to be useful to
mankind right
and i think that's a good thing for
everybody not just men but women as well
we also have to say that there are also
dudes that are [ __ ] destructive to
mankind sure
including these dudes that we're talking
about right now yeah and apathetic
[ __ ] are also
kind of [ __ ] destructive to me just
have something to contribute however
even if it's something small you have to
contribute in some kind of creative way
yeah even if it's just like even like
even if it's only to your own family
even like i said yeah it doesn't have to
be anything like [ __ ]
earth shattering but if you can make
something
like i said it even if it's something
it's like oh you make a youtube channel
that makes me laugh
right or you write a story that like
amuses me or you do something like that
that to me that's useful or you take
care of your family yeah
it's like you don't have to do
everything right like for general people
it's that you take care of your family
take care of your husband you take care
of your wife you take care of your kids
it's like that's enough you don't have
to like
yes it would be good if you could like
you know take care of more people than
that but it's like it doesn't matter if
you don't
because you know that is true i believe
that
all people though in general should
aspire to excellence
you should always you should but
excellent as you could possibly be
just don't be just don't don't be a
detriment to other people right
that's the deal that's what i'm saying
as long as you're not detrimental don't
be a dick
right don't be actively hostile toward
people don't be
like a pain in the ass for no reason
yeah it's like as long as you're not
doing that
just don't do harm you know what i'm
saying well it depends
don't do harm to decent people
there are bad people too yeah i mean
if you want to like punch someone that
is a serial killer then
that is fine no one will argue with that
i think they understand what we're
talking about right it's like you know
if somebody wants to kill somebody
that's a serial killer no one's going to
complain about that ever
well the law because the law says it's
not you it's not it's not your authority
to do that although honestly
you look at the law and [ __ ] if the
situation arose if they knew
later that that person was a serial
killer and somebody like took them out
i feel like no jury would convict that
person i don't really worry about the
law
okay well i'm just saying i don't think
anyone would convict that person
yeah just cover your own ass do what you
think is right
just watch your ass [ __ ] in general i
think it's just a good idea
just try to be a good person just don't
be a douche
apparently that's really hard for some
people i don't know why
but just don't be a douche
yeah i don't know why that's hard but
it's hard
but yeah so this dude apparently found
it very difficult not to be a douche
because
he went around killing like more than 50
people
so as i said uh so he gets so they
initially convicted or they initially
accused him of 36 murders he says oh
guess what
there's 20 more that you guys don't even
know about yet so he leads him to the
bodies or whatever
so he leads them to another uh several
other bodies including a couple other
kids he killed one in 1989
that he buried by a cemetery what not
now
three of the murders that he confessed
to
um they couldn't find a body that
uh corresponded to that uh confession
that doesn't mean he didn't kill them it
just meant that he either
forgot where he buried him or they
couldn't find the body or whatever so
i like i said i'm i'm erring on the side
of he probably killed 56 people
but they only charged him for 53 because
they could find enough evidence for the
last three that he
can uh that he confessed to
so they uh they put him in the
in the jail there they took him out he
did like reenactments of all the crime
scenes
i remember that [ __ ] they were in the
courtroom they had them in a damn
[ __ ]
cage they did yeah yeah they well you
know why they put them in a cage
because all of the families yeah the
victims they're afraid they were killed
basically we're like give him to us they
were going to tear that dude
lim from limb which
i mean a lot of photographs of him in
that damn cage in the corner i don't
think anyone would have been
particularly upset if he had been torn
limp by the victim's families i mean in
this case like i said i don't advocate
that kind of [ __ ] normally
but in this case um i think it's
completely understandable
um if your child had been killed by this
person and he had admitted it
showed them where the body was and
everything like that i don't really
think anyone would
blame you if you wanted to tear this
[ __ ]
tear that dude like into pieces i don't
think anyone something in fire pixie
wants
is asking dennis if she could if he
could answer some questions for her book
dennis is not with us i'm a dentist
impersonator
okay well what
what kind of questions are we talking
about
i'm a dentist impersonator
yeah yeah we need to get this one
[ __ ] done because
i want to cook i'm gonna cook some
indian food i'm getting [ __ ] hungry
really at this time oh okay no it's not
late at all it's still light out
oh my god is it really holy crap
i thought for some reason i thought it
was like no super late
still daytime it's only like 10 past
eight yeah it doesn't get dark until
nine years still laid out
it's florida yeah florida gets dark at
like nine in the evening
not even like 9 30 9 30. yeah yeah
so um initially they were trying to
there there was kind of a back and forth
about whether they were going to
go for an insanity offense because
clearly this dude was
had some problems let's say that but um
so they had like uh i believe six
different psychiatrists that
analyzed this dude like over a several a
day or a week period
and they came to the conclusion that
this dude was
sane and competent to stand trial
so they put him on trial and as you
mentioned earlier
uh when he was put on trial in uh 1992
they put him in a cage because uh all of
the
uh families of the victims basically
wanted to tear him
in from limb and kept telling the
authorities please give them to us we
want to kill him
and so they were worried about his
safety because you know
uh understandably so they put him in
this [ __ ] cage now during the trial
um so they shaved his head which was the
thing
that they usually did back then because
of lice and whatnot
so during the trial he i feel like
this was kind of a case where he was i
don't know if he was
intentionally trying to make it seem
like he was crazy
i kind of suspect that he was but when
he's in the cage
he was acting very um
erratic like he would sit in there he
would give some testimony he would break
out into song he would as i said earlier
pull his pants down and like shake his
dick at people
and be like look at this useless thing
and this is what caused everything and
that kind of [ __ ]
he would pull that kind of [ __ ] i think
he's full of [ __ ] i
kind of suspect as well i don't think he
was that stupid i think he
was trying to get an insanity plea and
get a lighter sentence
yeah i i kind of feel that he wasn't a
stupid person
he really wasn't and i don't think that
he was
crazy in the sense that he didn't know
what he was doing is wrong
he's crazy in the sense that a serial
killer is crazy yeah and
as i said and i think this is a good um
i think this is a good uh you know kind
of
metric is that legally
you're not insane in a court of law
unless you can't
determine the difference between right
and wrong no no he knew what that was
like if you're killing people and you
just be like yeah i killed the person
whatever
it's like you don't seem to like realize
that that's a bad thing to do
okay that's crazy but if you did make
some attempt to hide it
if you you you know then obviously you
knew what you were doing you knew what
you're doing was wrong
and that can't be classified as insanity
i think that's a good
you know rule of thumb yeah and that's
pretty much what they
went with this and i i do feel like he
was trying to like go
look how crazy i am you know thrusting
my penis at everyone
um you know talking about how useless it
is and that's what made me
kill everyone because i was impotent and
whatnot um
but i don't think it worked on anyone on
it honestly
i remember you know when this was going
down i was a kid i remember seeing them
and thinking that dude was [ __ ]
acting up
he reminded me he reminded me of
applewhite remember that [ __ ]
even though that's a different kind of
crazy but he wasn't that crazy
he was just crazy in the way that a
serial killer was crazy yeah
which that's a different type of yeah i
don't even know if i would call that
yeah you still know it's bad but you're
doing it anyway
yeah and i feel like the thing about
this was he tried to get a different
uh judge because the judge in this case
was clearly um not having it and he was
like not
they saw through biased in his favor so
for a long time he was like trying to
it's like hey
the judge is biased against me blah blah
defense attorney was arguing that as
well
but in the end they're asking if he had
stalkers no i don't think he had
stalkers
oh god i hope not no no no that was an
american phenomenon
i don't think that what's the matter
with us well it was a free
the united states is a free society
there wouldn't be any negative
repercussions if you were a fan
of a serial killer here matter of fact
they might put you on television if
you're a fan of him
but in the soviet union they might lock
your ass up
yeah i guess yeah so they they positive
outcomes no there's no positive outcomes
even for loser chicks
yeah cause like i don't really get that
i don't
like like i said i'm fascinated with
serial killers but
from a point of view of like this is an
alien mindset from a human
not that oh that's so sexy in the united
states i don't get that in the soviet
union if you were a woman and you
stepped forward [ __ ] as a fan they
would go oh you must have conspired with
him
you helped him didn't you that's what
would happen they'll take you away
yeah in the middle of the day they were
like you become a suspect immediately
then
i you know yeah because like i said i
don't
russia didn't play i don't know like
intellectually i understand that
[ __ ] like because some women have really
low self-esteem i get that um
and they're trying to become famous too
and yeah
it's like not only do you want to like
get with someone who can't
cheat on you because they're in prison
and there's that whole i can change him
thing because i'm super special it's a
narcissism thing
um some women have this weird thing
where it's like i'm gonna
rehabilitate the bad boy yeah um that's
kind of a big thing somebody said dennis
had a lot of hoes i don't think dennis
got a lot of hoes
did he though i don't think so because i
don't know i don't feel like he may be
like he wasn't the right age group he's
not super foxy you know i'm not saying
serial killers are super foxy but you
had to be he was younger and have a
friend right he wasn't one that would
inspire a lot of
like somebody like ted bundy or even
richard ramirez or somebody like that
was younger
that was kind of more more violent
conventionally attractive
you know you know with [ __ ] bunny
rabbit ears
i'm just you know i feel like dennis
just looked like a schlubby middleweight
yeah he was the slubby middle-aged dog
catcher
yeah and it's like unless you're into
schlubby she's dead that's
not a lot of women are not saying i
don't really
see anybody being all up in that no
because
not sexy sorry dennis
[Laughter]
just saying i'm not saying i find ted
bundy particularly attractive either
because i don't i'm just saying that
but that fits more well he looks more
like a normal
younger person like if he wasn't a
serial killer he would probably
there's a certain kind of woman that's
just into this the serial killer
bad boy i think like i said i think
as a woman personally like i said i
don't i'm i'm kind of an outlier woman
so i don't
pretend to understand how other women's
psychology is i would never
uh you know go there with that because
like everyone's different
but i do feel like there's a thing where
there is definitely a thing where you
feel like
you're the only one like this is a
serial killer this is a person that has
killed women in the past but you're
going to be the person that's going to
fix it
saves him or fixes him and everyone's
going to see you fixing him
that is a fantasy that a lot of women
have i mean if you read like romance
novels and [ __ ] like that's a whole
genre right that's a whole and the whole
messed up and the whole world's going to
see it
happen right yeah you're going to be the
the person you are so special that you
can make a serial killer
a normal person and it's all going to be
documented on television
that's what that's why i feel like
that's kind of
what it is i don't think it's anything
more than that i don't think that
there's any boils down
to three [ __ ] words [ __ ] be crazy
it's the [ __ ] be crazy factor
i don't know like i don't know it's
funny how how dudes always say that but
i i always found dudes way crazier yeah
women are crazier in much less
threatening ways this would be crazy
generally when dudes are crazy
it's obvious when dudes well when dudes
are crazy they'll
like shoot up a place yeah people die
women don't usually do that kind of [ __ ]
yeah they don't usually i mean women go
crazy
and maybe something bad happens but they
don't usually like shoot up a whole
[ __ ]
place or like blow up a whole building
so how much is left
not much to the chickatillo case why are
you getting all impatient yeah
it's getting late i'm keeping track of
the time
it's almost 8 30. it's almost 8 30. okay
all right so
what ended up happening like i said so
the defense attorney and him and they
were just kind of like oh the judge is
biased
and uh the judge what the judge ended up
doing was like
yeah well i hear your plea and hey let's
uh replace
the prosecutor instead so
so that's what he did so as it ended up
uh
he actually got uh
guilty of 52 counts of murder
death sentence for each and every one of
them
um they so they end up being
like basically what they did so they
gave him
essentially 52 deaf sentences
um now one of the
parents of one of the victims
when they were still in court he
actually ended up throwing something
at andre chicateel it was like kind of a
like a big
chunk of metal or something he ends up
throwing it at chickatillo which hit him
and then they were gonna arrest the
person that threw it but all the other
family members like gathered around that
person and like
prevented them from like uh arresting
that person
so october 14th of uh i believe it's
1990 or 91
so it took them
two days to read all of the murder
victims because like i said this was 52
cases so it took them all of one day and
then into the next day to read
all of the charges against the dude
because there were so many
uh he ends up being guilty of 52 of the
53
murders that he was uh you know accused
of
and he was found guilty for each one of
them
now when he got the sentence of guilty
and when the judge was basically like um
yeah you deserve to die for this [ __ ]
uh he had a little bit of a little
mantra in his little cage
uh kicking the bench and being like
it's like okay nobody wanted to hear
that [ __ ]
uh so they asked him if he wanted to
make a speech he would not
uh he didn't say anything and january
uh fourth 1994 and at this point the
soviet union had fallen
uh and you know so boris yeltsin was in
power i remember that yeah and they gave
him an opportunity to give
andre chicatilo a uh you know uh
appeal for clemency or is you know just
you know uh
due to life sentence instead of death
penalty mauricion said
no let's let's not so february 14th of
1994
valentine's day i don't know about
russia but it is the united states
they took chicotilo to a soundproof room
in the prison
and just [ __ ] shot him damn in the
side of the head that was the cheap way
of doing it they didn't [ __ ] round
i mean they [ __ ] the gas champers wow
just popped they just popped into the
[ __ ] head
and shot them and that's what they did
it's cheaper
it is yeah i mean when you think about
it yeah
i i mean like i said you can't feel too
bad for this guy no [ __ ] that dude
pretty much [ __ ] that dude anything else
in the aftermath
not really i mean like i said um they
made a movie
and it's on youtube if you want to watch
it because i watched most of it today
it's called citizen x
stephen ray is in it donald southerland
is in it
um and it's about this case fairly
accurate
they they they tried to keep it close to
the actual
case um and it's actually pretty good
i heard it was made for tv i don't
really know because like i said there's
a lot of swearing in it so i don't know
how much
how it was made for tv because there's a
lot of people saying [ __ ] it
but it was actually pretty good look at
you getting all
so what you guys got to say you guys got
anything to say about the show
any questions if you guys guys got any
questions now is the time
yeah it was actually it was actually now
that i think about it was an hbo movie
so it wasn't like made for
tv tv it was made for hbo which you can
swear on that show
saying that they saw the show all right
then well that was a good show
and um if you guys like the show go
ahead and like
share and subscribe
and jenny now when we're gonna see him
we'll see him when
we will probably do another live stream
tomorrow because
we're going to review that movie that we
want yeah okay we're going to do a movie
review tomorrow
because we watched a new horror movie
last night i'm not going to tell you
what it is yeah but we'll review it
tomorrow
we're going to tomorrow we will see you
guys tomorrow probably like two
probably three actually so we don't have
to get up too early
[Laughter]
okay see you guys tomorrow holy crap
we've been on for almost three and a
half hours yeah
all right so uh hopefully you guys
enjoyed the show i think i got all my
[ __ ] in
you did yeah it's all in there awesome
it's all in there
i just like i was nervous about the last
show that we did because i feel like we
didn't talk about most of the show
man this is a long [ __ ] show but i
feel like this one [ __ ] shows that's
good
that's a good show they're good they're
saying that was a great show i think i
got most of the [ __ ]
yeah i got most of the input we got it
in there as drunk as i am
yeah all right let me go right good let
me go good
all right tom wants to go cook some
dinner because it's
wherever where we are in florida it's 8
30 p.m at the moment man look he's
already leaving
i'm getting out of here all right
like share subscribe for more share with
all your
friends on social media do whatever you
do if you want to subscribe to the
patreon we have a patreon page we have a
blog
13 o'clock podcast.wordpress.com if you
want to give a
paypal donation it would be much
appreciated and we will see you
tomorrow we're going to do a movie
review probably matinee live
and we'll see you tomorrow bye